في انطباع عام وانا اتفق مع اصحاب هذا
الانطباع بانه مدننا ليست مدن صراحه مرضيه
من ناحيه انسنت المدن وقربها للانسان وليس
للاله من ناحيه التشوه البصري من ناحيه
جوده الطرق من ناحيه التنقل والحركه
احيانا اما عدم وجود خيارات او وجود زحام
شديد او وجود
شوارع يعني
مخجله من رداءه الاسفلت فيها فمشهد اداره
المدن صراحه مشهد محبط كان في مركزيه بشكل
او باخر في اتخاذ القرارات وهذا حقيقه
يعني يقتل اي عمل ابداعي في التخطيط
الحضري
[موسيقى]
هذا السقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا عمري
استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسولف معهم عن المستجدات ومستهدفات
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقه اليوم هو
معالي المهندس فهد البليهشي امين منطقه
المدينه المنوره والرئيس التنفيذي لهيئه
تطوير المدينه المنوره حلقه تناسب ان تكون
ختام الموسم
لانها تكلمت عن موضوع يهم الجميع موضوع
المدن السعوديه تكلمنا عن تحديات المدن
السعوديه ليش مدننا فيها نسب تشجير منخفضه
جدا ليش هي مدن ليست صديقه للانسان يواجه
المشاه فيها تحديات عشان يقضون مشاويرهم
ليش شوارعنا بهذا السوء ليش الحفريات
قاعده تهجم على كل شارع بمجرد ما ينتهى
ليش المدن غير الرئيسيه تواجه تحديات في
استقطاب الناس لها ومن ضمنها مدينه مدينه
المدينه المنوره
فتكلمنا بشكل عام عن مشاكل المدن وبعد ذلك
دخلنا في المدينه المنوره تحديدا وتحدثنا
عن ابرز ما حققوه لانه اماره المدينه
يبدو لي انها يعني قدمت نماذج ايجابيه في
التعامل مع هذه التحديات فسولفنا عن اللي
تحقق في موضوع مشاريع الانسنه مشاريع
التشجير توفير مسطحات المشاه سالت ضيفنا
على موضوع فكره انه يحطون ممشى في المدينه
وكانه باقي المدينه ليست مخصصه للمشي
فاتفق مع هذه الاشكاليه وشرح كيف ممكن هم
يتعاملوا معاها في المدينه المنوره وكيف
يبنون شبكه المشاه اللي تربط كل احتياجاتك
كساكل في المدينه المنوره سولفنا عن نموذج
من اجمل النماذج صراحه اللي هم تميزوا فيه
وهو استقطاب المستثمرين هم تجاوزوا دورهم
في تشغيل المدينه الى استقطاب المستثمرين
اللي يحسنون جوده سكان المدينه في
القطاعات الصحيه والقطاعات التعليميه
وغيرها
وبعد ذلك تحدثنا عن مجموعه من اسئلتكم
الثمينه
ايقافات الاراضي خطط التوسع في المدينه
الى اي اتجاه
تحديات
الشركه الرقابيه على
المحلات والمطاعم والمقاهي وبشكل عام
الفرص الاستثماريه في المدينه المنوره
اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو محمد
شرفتنا سعيد بوجودي معكم انا اللي سعيد
اخوي ابو عبد الرحمن على يعني الاستضافه
في استقرارات سقراط برنامج جميل ومميز
يحكي حكايه يعني يروي حكايه التحول في في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا التحول
العظيم فاشكرك على الدعوه وسعيد بوجودك
على قبول الدعوه بعد يعني محاولات متكرره
الحمد لله نجحت المحاوله الاخيره فاحنا
سعداء فيك وقبل ما نحكي عن حكايه التحول
في امانه
خلينا بعد شوي واروح لليابان واقول عطنا
من ذكرياتك في اليابان لانها هي عاده كذا
يسمونها كوكب منفصل عن كوكب الارض خصوصا
في اداره المدينه نفسها اداره المدن هناك
جوده الحياه نظام
الحياه فعطل من ذكريات دراسه الماجستير في
اليابان جميل هو حقيقه ما كان درست
ماجستير هو كان عمل عملت في اليابان نعم
عمل فحد الشركات الخاصه يمكن زي ما تعرف
جامعه البترول قبل تتخرج فيه تدريب تعاوني
سبع شهور يعني تحتاج تقضيه في اي مكان
فيعني جاءت الفرصه وفضلت انه يكون خارج
المملكه وزاد فرصه في احد الشركات
التي تعمل يعني مع شركه ارامكو في تنفيذ
المصافي البترول تدربت هناك الفتره هذه
سبعه شهور وانتهت الفتره التدريب بوظيفه
رجعت كملت
يعني الترم المتبقي في الجامعه مباشره
ثاني يوم بعد الانتهاء انتقلت لهناك كان
انت سبع شهور دراسه سبع شهور كان تدريب
تدريب على تراس العمل نعم وبعدين رجعت
اشتغلت فيها اشتغلت فيها اشتغلت
سنتين متواصله بشكل متواصل وسنه يعني
متقطعه بين الخبر وبين تقريبا ثلاث سنوات
ونص اربع سنوات وش اهم ذكرياتك في هذيك
الدوله والله يعني كثيره جدا جدا تعرف ما
احنا متعودين احنا كنا نعمل في في بيئه
جديده او او يعني على مستوى الشخصي انك
تخرج يعني اول وظيفه لك في في بيئه جديده
في مكان يعني الثقافه جديده نوعا ما يعني
متحفظه بشكل او باخر صحيح انه كانت الشركه
شركه يعني عالميه وتعمل في اكثر من من
دوله لكن يبقى الاحتكاك اليومي
بالشعب وبالزملاء كذا اح يعني حديث هذا
حقيقه استفدت منه بشكل كبير عن مستوى
الشخصي وعلى المستوى العملي يعني الاعلى
مدى الفتره اللي بقيتها هناك حقيقه او
جلست فيها هناك
اكتسبت كثير من المهارات اللي انعكست
اليوم على شخصيتي
وكذلك على الالتزام بالعمل وتفاصيل هذا
اللي هو موجود اصلا عندنا يعني في في
ثقافتنا وفي في قيمنا لكن مؤصل بشكل كبير
هناك وموجود يعني ما كان حقيقه في موضوع
الالتزام والبصمه والدوام وكذا ما فيه لكن
تجد الكل حقيقه موجود على يعني في الوقت
الخروج الساعه عشره يعني من تسعه الصباح
الى عشره في الليله تسعه في الليل يعني
هذا هذا طبعا معدل طبيعي للعمل بشكل يعني
متواصل مرت ايام يعني برمضان كنت افضل
الساعه تسعه وعشره بالليل يعني انسى وهذا
وهذا يعني اعطاني انطباع على بيئه العمل
كيف او بيئه البيئه بالعموم كيف تؤثر على
الشخص يمكن موقف من المواقف السريعه
في البدايات ممكن تخرج الصباح للدوام امشي
لمسافه وبعدين اركب المترو وبعدين امشي
المسافه يعني بسيطه عشر دقائق او شيء كنت
اشوف ناس تجري استغرب يعني ما في التزام
ما في بصمه
انتبهت لنفسي فجاه اني انا اجري كذلك بعد
فتره مدري متى بدات حقيقه
بهذا الفعل لكن هذا الدليل حقيقه انه
البيئه يعني تؤثر بشكل او باخر سواء
بالعمرانيه او الاشخاص او كذا تؤثر بشكل
او باخر على على الانسان وهذا اللي اليوم
قاعد احاول يعني اطبقه في بيتي وفي اسرتي
وفي كذا وفي اماكن العمل الحقيقه اللي
اعمل فيها ان البيئه عنصر مهم والقدوه
عنصر مهم من عناصر يعني اي نجاح بالاضافه
الى الى ذلك يعني يمكن نقطه اخيره هو
موضوع الصوره الذهنيه بناء الصوره الذهنيه
للدول والمدن والاشخاص
يعني شيء مهم جدا يعني صح انه نتكلم على
الكوكب الاخر وتميزهم وكذا وكذا لكن حقيقه
هم شعب مميز رائع
لكن عنده يعني ايجابياته الكثيره جدا اللي
موجوده عندنا وعندنا حقيقه اكثر منها في
قيمنا وفي في يعني ثقافتنا
فالتسويق الصوره الذهنيه للمدن للدول
وللشعوب اعتقد انه مهم جدا ويمكن كان
ينقصنا سابقا وهذا لعلنا يعني
كثير من اليوم الاعمال او البرامج او كذا
تحكي هذا الموضوع او متوجه لهذا الموضوع
ولو بنقول ابو محمد وش اكثر شيء افتقدته
لما انتقلت من مدن اليابان الى مدن
السعوديه وش اكثر شيء فقدته المشي هنا
عجيب اي نعم يعني للاسف وهذا حقيقه هو
اليوم التحدي الاكبر كيف انه المدينه مثلا
زي طوكيو مكتظه
بمساحات يعني كثافات جدا مرتفعه وكذا لكن
تجد فيها حقيقه المشي سيره التنقل
الاساسيه وبعد كذا تجي الدراجات وبعدين
يجي النقل العام ويعني السيارات هذا يعني
شيء غير غير منطقي اصلا
يمكن تجربه كذا جربتها في في بعض الايام
اخر الاسبوع استاجر سياره كذا واروح في
اماكن
سويتها مره او مرتين وقفت يعني صعب جدا
ايجاد الموقف تكاليف الموقف غاليه جدا
المسافات طويله جدا وصعبه ويعني تاخذ وقت
طويل جدا فالخيار الامثل هو انك تمشي
لافضل من ذله اذا مسافات طويله اتكلم على
كيف تركب النقل عام سواء كان حافلات او
متر وتنتقل فيه بشكل يعني
ومنظم طبعا النقل العام بشكل او باخر
يرتبط بالتجربه كل ما كانت منظمه ومرتبه
وكذا كل ما كانت جاذبه اكثر حقيقه وواضحه
وتكاليفها معقوله وبعدين اقل من 18 لهم
يعني اسعار تشجيعيه اكثر من 65
فباختصار موضوع
كل العناصر الاخرى اعتقد انه يعني موجوده
عندنا بل بالعكس يمكن عندنا المتعه اكبر
بكثير في في العواصر الاجتماعيه والعمل
الاجتماعي والوجود الاجتماعي في المنظومه
يعني او في بيئتنا وثقافتنا وشكله لن يعني
شكل هذا الشيء اللي افتقدته جيت تعوضه
لمصرت
عن بيتها ما شاء الله مراتب وهذا مدخل جيد
لحلقتها محمد احمد سعدان نستضيفك بصفتك
امين منطقه المدينه المنوره والرئيس
التنفيذي لهيئه تطوير المنطقه
فخلينا نبدا بالتعريف بهالجهازين الفرق
بينهم ادوارهم وبعدين ممكن تنورنا اكثر
وتذكرنا الفرق بينهم وما بين اجهزه اخرى
بالنسبه للبعض الناس تبدو متداخله مثل
اماره المدينه المنوره مثل المدينه اللي
هي شغاله برضو هناك وزاره البلديه
والسكان ناخذ كذا ملمح سريع ونفهم فيه
المشهد جميل الامانه منطقه المدينه او
الامانات في المملكه يعني امانه المدينه
خلنا نبدا من امانه المدينه امر بتاسيس
الملك طيب الله صراحه عام 1344 يعني
تقريبا انا الان مئه سنه يعني منذ انشاء
تاسيسه وهو حقيقه احد اولى الاجهزه اللي
يعني انشات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دورها يعني لها عدد كبير من الادوار يعني
نقدر نحصرها في موضوع التخطيط المكاني
بشكل او باخر انواع المخططات واستخدامات
الاراضي وكذا هذا دور من ادوار الامانه
اللي اليوم الهيئه اشتركت فيه او اصبح دور
من ادوار الهيئه الامر الاخر تنفيذ مشاريع
البنيه التحتيه نتكلم على مزارع صرف مياه
امطار اناره طرق جسور انفاق هذه كلها بشكل
او باخر هي مشاريع البنيه التحتيه الحدائق
كذلك انشاء الحدائق وصيانه التشغيل
المرافق هذه يعني تنشئها
وتشتغل على صيانتها والاهتمام فيها
الاخر هو تمكين الاعمال التراخيص انا
دائما احب اطلق عليه انه هو تمكين اعمال
اكثر منه ترخيص ورقابه كيف ان نمكن
الاعمال سواء كان القطع الخاص او قطاع
الحكومي حتى القطاع الحكومي او القطع
الثالث والقطاعات المختلفه كيف نمكن
الاعمال
نراقبها او او نشرف عليها بشكل او باخر
على ترخيصه وعلى الامتثال والتزام فيها
يعني هذه
الادوار الامانه موضوع التخطيط المدينه او
او تخطيط الحضري الشامل للمدينه ليس من
ادوار الامانه هو طبعا دور مشترك في
السابق كان من ادوار الامانات بشكل او
باخر وزاره الشؤون وهي تقوم بهذا الدور
يعني مع الامانات الان في ظل وجود الهيئات
هيئات التطوير هي من تعمل على موضوع
التخطيط الشامل والتخطيط الاقليمي خلينا
نتعرف على الهيئه ودورها نعم الهيئه دور
لهيئه التطوير هو التخطيط الاستراتيجي
للمنطقه
اتكلم على تخطيط الاستراتيجي كل انواع
المخططات مخطط استراتيجي مخطط اقليمي
المخططات المحليه هذا واحد من ادوار
الرئيسيه كذلك موضوع التنسيق بين
المشروعات او او المشاريع المختلفه سواء
كان مسرع الحكوميه او القطاع الخاص هذه
كذلك بدور من ادوار الهيئه كيف تنسق بين
هذه المشروعات موضوع برضو كذلك مهم موضوع
توفير البيانات الحضريه المختلفه للمدينه
كيف انه هذا البيانات تكون موجوده متوفره
لا تدعم اتخاذ قرار سواء كان للهيئه او
للجهات الاخرى سواء كان قطاعيه اللي على
مستوى الوطني المركزيه او حتى على مستوى
الداخلي امر اخر يعني او اخير هو موضوع
اقتراح التشريعات وهذا هو عنصر مهم جدا
راح نتكلم عنه لاحقا في في التفاصيل في
كلامنا في تفاصيل الكلام على اداره المدن
اقتراح التشريعات او التوصيه بتشريعات
معينه لمدينه معينه في في نطاق محدد اللي
نرميها مثلا اقتصاديا او ينميها اجتماعيا
او لان موضوع المركزيه المركزيه في اتخاذ
القرار التخطيطي هو يعني سبب حقيقه له
ايجابيات كثيره لكن له سلبيات كثيره الدور
الاخر اللي ذكرته دور الاماره المنطقه
اماره المنطقه هي يعني امير المنطقه
والحاكم الاداري
للمنطقه عنده جهاز يعني متكامل يعمل على
تنسيق الجهود بين الجهات الدعم
الامني الدعم والتمكين للقطاعات المختلفه
لتنفيذ يعني اعمالها ومشاريعها ويشرف
عليها بشكل يعني اداري في
انها تقوم باعمالها بشكل سليم صحيح وزاره
البلديه وزاره البلديه هي الذراع التشريعي
او او الغطاء التشريعي المركزي
للامانات في العموم كل الامانات ترجع فيها
ترجع لها بشكل يعني مباشر التشريعات
والتنظيمات المختلفه النماذج المختلفه هي
اللي تكون فيه يعني مشغل المدينه
مرجعيتك الاوضح والاقرب هي الوزاره ولا
الهيئه ولا الاماره نتكلم مكانيا
التخطيطيا من ناحيه التخطيطيه هي الهيئه
يعني في حوكمه واضحه بين الهيئه والامانه
في هذا الجانب وفي بالعكس عمل مشترك
وقاعد يدعم في هذا الجانب بشكل كبير
مكانيا وزاره الشرقيه هي المظله المشرفه
الاسراف الاداري والتشريعي وكذا اغلب
التشريعات اللي تجي على المستوى الوطني هي
تيجي من وزاره الشؤون القرويه
والاماره ما في علاقه مباشره لا طبعا
الامر هي اشراف تشرفه على الاعمال في
المدينه بشكل كامل في اداري وتمكين انا
اقول والله يعني الامارات هي ممكنه للعمل
وداعمه للعمل بشكل كبير حقيقه ابو محمد
انا ودي ادخل على على صلب يعني موضوع
الحلقه اللي هو موضوع المدن السعوديه احنا
بنتكلم بشكل عام بعدين ندخل على الحاله
حقت المدينه المنوره
في انطباع عام وانا اتفق مع اصحاب هذا
الانطباع بانه مدننا ليست مدن صراحه مرضيه
احنا الحمد لله في خير وفي نعمه وفي امن
وامان لما نتكلم على نواحي عديده بس لما
تتكلم على وين نستحق وين تستحق ان تكون
مدن السعوديه الوضع ما هو مرضي من ناحيه
انسنت المدن وقربها للانسان وليس للاله من
ناحيه التشوه البصري من ناحيه جوده الطرق
من ناحيه التنقل والحركه احيانا اما عدم
وجود خيارات او وجود زحام شديد او وجود
شوارع يعني
مخجله من رداءه الاسفلت فيها
الحدائق والمرافق العامه صراحه في يعني
قصص لا تنتهي من البشاعه في هذه الاماكن
احيانا تلاقي حديقه كامله كلها ثيل اللي
هو ملعب جولف وهذا لا يعطيك ظل ولا يعطيك
يعني
استهلاك محدود للمياه في بلد صحراوي نادره
فيه المياه او تلاقيه فجاه كذا امين قرر
من راسه وقلب لك شارع كامل الشارع الاشجار
وركب لك بلاستيكات على شكل اشجار نخيل
شوارع دائري محطوط فيها نخيل اللي هي لا
تعطيك ظل وتستهلك مياه عاليه وتتطلب صيانه
وعنايه واخذ التمر وما ادري ايش وتلقيح
والى اخره
فمشهد اداره المدن صراحه مشهد محبط ولا
يوازي تطلعات
وطموحات سكان المدن السعوديه فبدي ابدا من
هذه النقطه واسالك كخبيل وليس كامين وش
كانت مشكله المدن السعوديه وبعدين ندخل
على الكيس حق المدينه المنوره كيف تعاملته
مع هذا التحديات
خليني انا اخذك شويه مشكله المدن السعوديه
تاتي ما حقيقه من الثوره الصناعيه الاخيره
وهذه ترى المشكله بشكل او باخر بنسب معينه
هي موجوده في كل مدن العالميه يعني
التحديات ليش اول شيء موضوع التخطيط
الحضري عمليه ينبغي الا تنتهي يعني موضوع
التخطيط الحضري مستمر طالما استمرت المدن
وعمر المدن ترى عمر طويل جدا جدا والتغيير
اللي يصير فيها يمكن اثره يبان لاعلى لكن
الاثار الاكبر في المستقبل واللي اليوم
احنا نعيشه هو ترى نتيجه يعني عشرات اذا
ما كان مئات السنين من من الانظمه
والتشريعات والتنفيذ
يعني عمر المدن عمر طويل العمليه التخطيط
الحضري ينبغي ان لا تنتهي مجرد ما تقول
والله انا انتهيت كذا لان الاحتياجات
الانسان تختلف
من الناس كانت يعني اقساط طموحه ان تكون
في ممرات امنه للمرور يعني الشخصي او مرور
الدواب الى انه والله اليوم السيارات الى
الى الى يعني راح ننتقل لموضوع سيره ذاتيه
القياده وننتقل لاشياء اخرى يعني سيارات
كهربائيه هذه الان برضه متطلبات جديده راح
تنشا وفي الخير يعني عندك مدن قائمه
واقع المملكه والمدن السعوديه ما هو بعيد
عن بعض المدن العالميه يمكن الكلام اللي
بقوله ترى يعني قبل التحول قبل رؤيه
المملكه نعم
وكان حقيقه العمل
ربما يكون صحيح في وقته ربما هذه الكوادر
والاحتياجات كذلك تختلف والتحديات والتغير
والمناخي وهذي كلها كان اشياء مو موجوده
العالميين
كان في مركزيه بشكل او باخر في اتخاذ
القرارات وهذا حقيقه يعني يقتل اي عمل
ابداعي في التخطيط الحضري ليش لانه لا
يمكن انه كل الحلول تنتج يعني من منظار
واحد او من مكان واحد المدن تختلف طبيعتها
تختلف في مدن ساحليه في مدن طبيعيه في مدن
يعني بيئتها جيده وفيها مياه في مدن لا
صحراويه مملكه قاره شاسعه يعني
المركزيه بشكل او باخر كانت مطلوبه لقله
الكوادر كانت مطلوبه للاهداف يعني محدوديه
المبالغ كل التفاصيل هذه كلها مطلوبه لكن
اليوم هذه الحمد لله تغيرت المركزيه تؤدي
لان والله من كل مخطط لازم يكون في ثلاثين
بالمئه نسبه من المساحه على الخدمات
المدارس كذا والمساجد كذا يعني حفظ محفوظه
تماما هذا طب هل نحتاج مدارس هل نحتاج نوع
هذا من المدارس هل احتاج المساجد في
الاماكن هذه هل احتاج حدائق يعني الحقيقه
في بعض المحافظات المدينه هي كلها حديقه
المحافظه المحافظه كلها جميله وكذا ما
تحتاج حتى تنفذ في حديقه اضافيه جزر وسطيه
تجدها مثلا وتلقاها كلها مبلطه نفس المواد
في كل مدن المملكه بشكل يعني
نوعا ما او شيء انه مقزز الامر الاخر من
صحه الطرق يعني كبيره جدا المواد هي نفسها
في كل المدن وهذا يعني
ربما سعوديه ولا مستدام وبعدين كل ما تنفذ
الطرق الواسعه الشاسعه في اماكن في
محافظات او في مدن صغيره ترى كل ما تحتاج
تشغيل وتحتاج الصيانه الاهتمام وكذلك تؤثر
بشكل او باخر على البيئه
يعني الموضوع الشوارع في الاربعين متر
وكذا في وسط احياء تجد كذا معناته اقدر
اسرع فيها وهي بالانطباع يعني انا انا
مارس هذا الشيء ويمكن لاي احد ممكن
بسرعه وهذا داخل تلقى حي سكني هذه كلها
تؤدي حقيقه ادت الى الى الى يعني اللي
احنا نشوف اليوم بالاضافه لذلك طبعا ما هو
عذر لكن النمو الغير مسبوق للمملكه في
فتره يعني قصيره جدا والتنميه السريعه ادت
لبعض الملاحظات هذه كذلك موضوع افتقار كان
ما عندنا حقيقه تطوير عقاري مميز تجد حي
السكني يتم تنفيذه على مدى اربعين سنه
خمسين سنه هذا يبني وذاك يبني وذاك يا
ابني وكذا وكل واحد يطلب خدمات مختلفه
وشركات الخدمات توصل بشكل منفصل فينتج عن
هذا الامر الاخر في جانبين جانب التنوع ما
في يعني مشهد حضري او او كود عمراني صحيح
واضح الناس تلتزم فيه فتلقاه يعني في
اجتهادات وتعرف الجانب الاذواق وكذا تختلف
وكذلك حتى الطرق الاكواد الطرق يعني مرنه
نوعا ما ما تحاكي الجوانب هذه فتجد انه في
في اشكاليه هذه كلها تنتج عن يعني تنتج
لنا المنتج الحالي او او المنتج اللي يعني
عشناه في الفلفل في المدى التسعين سنه
المئه سنه الماضيه ونتج عنه هذا الوضع
اللي موجود الشيء الجيد في التحول او في
رؤيه المملكه انه هذا الامور بدت يعني
تنحل بشكل كبير جدا ما راح يعني ما راح
نشوفها اليوم صعب جدا اليوم قاعدين نشوف
نماذج في اماكن محدده في مدري فين لكن
اعتقد النتيجه خلال عشر سنوات القادمه راح
تغير وجه المدن السعوديه بالعموم ان ما
كانت المدن الرئيسيه حتى المحافظات والمدن
الفرعيه ومن هنا خلينا ندخل على تجربه
المدينه المنوره صراحه انا اسمع كثير عن
اللي صاير في المدينه المنوره وهو حراك
يسبق متوسط ما نسمعه في بقيه المدن بشكل
عام ظنيت مبالغات اعلاميه ولا انكم في
التسويق فزوره المدينه انا زرت المدينه مع
والدتي وابنائي قبل سنه او او قبل عشر
شهور
واتعمدت اني اروح للاماكن اللي تنشرون
صورها في تويتر جده قبى وبعض المسارات
اللي اللي انشاتوها اجتمعت مع مجموعه من
الشباب المدينه رتبوا لي واكرموني بجلسه
عشاء من اروع ما يكون وقعدت تسمع منهم
صراحه في في حاله رضا وتفاؤل على التحركات
طموحاتهم لا تزال كبيره ولا زالوا ينتظرون
منك الكثير لكنهم على الاقل يقولون في
حراك في واحد فاهم ايش نبغى وقاعد يتحرك
ودائما يذكرون يعني
الوصفه السحريه تمكين الامير فيصل والامير
سعود
وقدرات ابو محمد
وجهود التنفيذيه فخلينا نتكلم على تجربه
المدينه ايش ابرز ما تحقق في تغيير وتصحيح
المشاكل التي حكينا عنها في مدن السعوديه
نتكلم على المدينه يعني في تطوير عند
تطوير اي مدينه كذا لازم نفهم ايش ميزه
التنافسيه ميزه وايش المطلوب بالضبط حنا
نتكلم على مدينه يعني
عريقه مرتبطه بالتاريخ الاسلامي بشكل كبير
جدا
ما حقيقه ما دخلوا المدينه من مكان الا
خلفه قصه ولا تشريع ولا ايه ولا حديث ولا
كذا هذا هذا هذي ميزه عظيم المدينه
وبشكل او باخر اليوم نحاول قدر المستطاعنا
اننا نستغلها حتى في تسميه الشوارع في
اعاده تسميه بعض الاماكن في بعض الساحات
لانه يعني عندنا جانبين عندنا سكان
المدينه واللي حنا مسؤولين عن يعني
تجربتهم وجوده الحياه في انهم يعني ينعمون
بحياه جيده وعندنا زائر المدينه تكلم على
مستهدف 30 مليون اليوم يعني نتكلم على 12
مليون سنويا قاعد يزورون المدينه ويعني
انعمون فيها ومسؤولين عن اثراء تجربتهم في
المدينه المنوره يعني مقصد لهم فكيف نسري
تجربتهم بدل والله ما يروح فقط الحرم
ويعني بعض الاماكن غير منظمه ويعني يمشي
فكيف انا مثل التجربه في انه يجلس فتره
اطول نستفيد من من يعني من وجودهم بشكل او
باخر
التنميه الاقتصاديه تتبع هذا الجانبين
جانب جوده الحياه السكان لانه كل ما يعني
ان الشط جوده الحياه او او كان في جوده
حياه في المكان كل ما صار في حراك وفي
متعه سكان المدينه يصيرون يستمتعون في
المدينه بدل ما هو الله فقط يعني فيه احد
المخططين الحاضرين الفرنسيين يقول والله
في مدن للنوم او يعني اطلع مفهوم في مدن
للنوم فعلا في مدن عالميه هي مدن للنوم
اذا لو احد ينام فيها ويشتغل ويتوكل على
الله اذا جاي يستمتعوا على كذا هذا يروح
لمكان اخر فهنا يعني جاء الاهميه انه كيف
انه يكون فيه
نظام صحي وهذا حقيقه سمو الامير فيصل كان
يعني من اولوياته وما زال يعني هذا
الموضوع من اولوياته كيف يكون في نظام صحي
جيد سواء كان قطع حكومي او خاص كيف يكون
فيه وهذا انعكس على حد اعمالنا يكون فيه
نظام تعليمي جيد سواء كان على المستوى
الحكومي او الخاص كيف تكون في ترفيه مناسب
وجيد يعني هذه هذا الثلاثي هو ثلاثي مهم
جدا في هذا وناخذ مثال على كل واحد منهم
جميل انا اتكلم اذا جيت اتكلم على مثلا
الجانب الصحي عندنا في المدينه مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي يعني في الامر فيه
خادم الحرمين الشريفين كفاله فرع لمستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي في المملكه في عندنا
في الرياض في جده الثالث في المدينه هدف
يعني الان موجود ويعمل ويعمل بشكل كامل
وهذا وحده من الاشياء الاساسيه في عندنا
كذلك مستشفيات الحكوميه المختلفه في
برنامج التحول الصحي واعمالهم فيها وهذا
عندهم حقيقه يعني ما اقدر اتكلم عنهم لكن
عندهم جهود كبير وسمو الامير فيصل مركز
يعني بشكل كبير انا وانا طالع لك الان كان
يكلمني على مستشفى من المستشفيات ويعني
اشكاليه من الاشكاليات اللي نقدر نحلها
ونشتغل عليها يعني وندعم فيها
كذلك عندنا مستشفيات الخاصه حاولنا نستقطب
يعني ابرز الاسماء اليوم تحت الانشاء
اسمين من اكبر الاسماء اللي موجوده مستشفى
الحبيب مستشفى الفقي كلها تحت الانشاء وفي
مراحل يعني متقدمه
في استقطابها العمالقه الصحيين للمدينه
جيد مثلا في حاله مستشفى الحبيب هو
الايجار ايجار الارض لفتره طويله
ومحاوله يعني التفاوض معهم حتى تواصلت
معاهم
انتوا
هذا واحد من ادوارد زي ما قلت لك والله
اداره المدينه مجرد ما تستوعب الميزه
التنافسيه وتستوعب النقاط الضعف والقوه في
المدينه تبدا تشتغل بناء على كذا كيف
اقنعتوهم يجون
الرغبه الاساسيه لهم يعني موجوده والحاجه
كذلك في المدينه والقدره والقوه والفراغ
اللي موجود الامر الاخر كيف انه اليوم
اصبحت عندنا نقدر ناجر لمده خمسين سنه في
اماكن يعني جيده في الامانه فكان هذا يعني
بعد نقاشات وخيارات على مدى 11 شهر يعني
اختاروا المكان واليوم يعني عمل حفيف جدا
قاعدين يشتغلون فيه في التنفيذ مستشفى
مثلا سليمان فقيه نفس الشيء مستشفى خاص
مميز في احد المستشفيات المميزه اعتقد في
المملكه موجود في جده نفس الشيء كان فيه
يعني ربط بينهم وبين احد الاوقاف في
المدينه في انه ينشؤون طبعا عملت الهيئه
والامانه وطبعا بتوجيه الامير فيصل على
التمكين فانه والله كيف تكون فين يكون
المكان كيف تكون العلاقه كيف تكون
الارتفاعات كيف يكون التصميم كيف يكون في
تسريع في التمكين العمل والترخيص وهذا
الجوانب واليوم مراحله جدا متقدمه في
التنفيذ اعتمدتها ما توقع افتتاح المستشفى
اعتقد في الحبيب
الفتره خمس المستشفى سليمان الفقيه تقريبا
25 هذا ما يلغي طبعا
المراكز الصحيه الاصغر لانها هي مهمه سواء
كان مراكز صحيه الحكوميه النموذجيه وهذا
يعني وزاره وتجمع الصحي في المدينه يبدو
الفيديو كبير
والامانه تمكن في تحديد المواقع في تحديد
الاماكن في كذا
والقطاعات الصحيه او الخاصه الصغيره في
كذلك نفس الشيء فاول عنصر في جوده الحياه
هو
العنصر الخدمات الصحيه وهذا اللي يتحقق
جزء كبير منه الامثله اللي ذكرتها قبل ما
نغادرها لموضوع التعليم انا سؤال جاي من
احد الاصدقاء يقول انه انا استاجرت ارض
للامانه وبعد فتره قالوا لي انه الارض هذي
فيها مشكله لانها تبع شخص اخر ونفس هذه
المشكله صارت مع الحبيب ومع مستثمر
الاخرين ذكرهم فصراحه يعني مره شيء غريب
انه اراضي الامانه اللي هي مفرمه اضمن ارض
من خاليه من الشوائب والعوائق اللي يتعقد
معاكم يبلش بعدين فيكم ويتدبس
فرديه جدا وبسيطه للحبيب على مستوى الحبيب
المستشفى الحبيب طال عمرك موجود ويعمل
بشكل يعني الاشكالي اللي موجود الاشكاليه
بسيط وحلت
ما هي يعني والله الارض هي ملك الامانه
وتعمل فيها في جزء من الارض يعني جزء بسيط
من الارض ملك ملك شخص اخر او او يعني في
ادعاء للملكيه وهذا اليوم يعالج نظامه
ويعالج لكن انا هاكد لك انه تعمل حقيقه
انك تزور المشروع ما وقف المشروع ابدا
ابدا ابدا يعمل على مدى حتى 24 ساعه في
مرحله الحفر فهذا الشيء الجيد والليله
يمكن وبعدين فيه ترى انظمه يعني تربط هذا
كله قد تصير احداث فرديه وهذا نتيجه
النشاط احيانا من تنشط وتعمل تطلع بعض
الملاحظات اللي قاعد بتطرق لها موضوع
التوثيق وتحصل الاصول والجوانب الاخرى هذا
الجانب الصحي طيب العنصر الثاني التعليم
وش سويتوا بجانب التعليم كذلك هذه مهمه
مهام يعني وزاره التعليم الاساسيه لكن على
مستوى المدارس الخاصه نفس الشيء عندنا عدد
من المدارس او يعني ثلاث اربع مدارس
استقطبناها احدها يعني مدارس مداك انشات
في المدينه عباره عن وقف مدارس متميزه جدا
كانت مبهره جدا بدعوه منهم الله يجزاهم
خير زرتها واتجولت فيها وكانت ايضا يعني
نموذج غير عادي والعربي انجليزي بتوازن
عالي جدا فيعني بس تاكيد على كلامك انه
فعلا مدارس مميزه في نشوءها طبعا يمكن ما
في دور رئيسي في في الامانه الا انه هو
يمكن التراخيص وتمكين تسريع الاعمال
وتحديد النطاق وتحديد كذا هذه الاعمال
اليوميه للامانه اللي تقوم فيها مع اي احد
باي طبيعه لكن لان مدركين على الاهميه
الموضوع يمكن نسرع فيه بشكل اكثر اكبر
وانا كشخص اتشرف انه سمو الامير فيصل
شرفني في انه يكون عضو مجلس اداره معهم في
العمل لاهتمامي حقيقي الشخصي بالتعليم
وعندي يعني شغف في هذا الجانب خصوصا انه
المدارس واعده الامر الاخر هو حقيقه
المدارس عندنا يعني مدارسنا مدارس متقدمه
هذه كلها اسماء من من المملكه استقطبت
ويعني استاجروا
نعم نعم وما زلنا نتواصل ترى وندعو حقيقه
لاي مدارس متميزه انها تكون في المدينه
سواء كان قطعه صحيه وتعليمي لانه يعني
نحقق فيه اكثر من جانب جوده الحياه وكذلك
اهداف المختلفه حقت الامانه وعندكم جامعات
وايش الجامعات اللي عندكم عندنا جامعه
طيبه في المدينه وعندنا الجامعه الاسلاميه
كذلك وعندنا جامعات خاصه جامعه الامير
مقرن جامعه خاصه متميزه في يعني مجال
الامن السيبراني في موضوع الهندسه التصميم
الداخلي والمعماريه وعندنا كليات الصحيه
كليه الريان واحده من الكليات الصحيه هذه
كلها موجوده في المدينه وفيها خريجين
وخريجين مميزين جدا في قطاعات مختلفه وفي
جزء ثالث اللي هو موضوع
الركن الثالث اللي هو الترفيه او او
خليني بس ارجع لك على موضوع التعليم
الحكومي بشكل سريع
اليوم احنا في المدينه بعد سنه تقريبا حسب
ما اعلن وزاره التعليم راح تكون عندنا صفر
مدارس مستاجره
في بعد سنه بعد سنه
نعم الان في
الان في اكثر من 60 مدرسه تحت الانشاء
شركه تطوير التعليم اكثر من سته مدرسه
بتصاميم جدا مميزه ورائعه وكذا دور
الامانه حقيقه استشعار الامانه في المشكله
وفهمها لها وكذلك متابعه الامير فيصل
ومتابعته لهذا الملف بشكل يعني
متخصص في هذا الجانب
توفير الاماكن توفير الاراضي وهذا واحد من
الادوار الرئيسيه تحديد مواقع الاراضي
بناء على الكثافات السكانيه واتجاهات
النمو الطبيعي والتراخيص التسريع تسريعه
يمكن بتقول لي والله هذا شيء طبيعي وعمل
يعني واجب من الواجبات نعم لكن اليوم
معامله التعليم تختلف عن معامله المواطن
تختلف عن معامله الهاب انا حقيقه عندي
يعني انا عندي شخص في المكتب خاص بالتعليم
ما يعني تواصل مع مديره التعليم في
المدينه يعني رجل نشط ومتميز يتواصل معه
بشكل مباشر يتواصل معي بشكل مباشر لكن
لتخليص الامور ومتابعتها ومحاوله لها
هذا جانب مهم كذلك يعني ان نصل في في وقت
من الاوقات قبل يعني سنوات بسيطه كنا 50%
من مدارس مستاجره ويعني عملوا الزملاء في
التعليم على تقليص هذا انه يكون والله صفر
المدارس مستاجره هذا اعتقد انه عمل يعني
كبير يمكن دورنا فيه بسيط جدا دور التعليم
اكبر ودعم وتمكين الاماره ومتابعتها الملف
هذا اكبر بكثير لكن استشعارا باهميه
الموضوع كيف انه نبدا نركز عليه ونحله
جميل الركن الثالث الترفيه نتكلم على كل
عناصر الترفيه سواء كان انت اليوم عندك
شريحه السكان زي ما ذكرت لك او شريحه
الزوار كيف انه تكون فيه وجهات مختلفه
وجهات مختلفه من ناحيه وجود الاشياء
الاساسيه اتكلم على الاحتياج اليومي
للمطاعم المقاهي هذا الجانب كذلك اليوم
بدينا في المدينه على موضوع تفعيل المزارع
كيف يعني نرفع من اقتصاديات المزارع هذه
انه نمنع تحويلها ونمنع استخدامها يعني
بشكل مضر بيئيا لكن نسمح باستخدامات بيئيه
جيده وهذا بدات تتوسع المدينه فيه وهذا
واحده من الميزه اللي موجوده فيه في
المدينه كذلك اليوم عندنا اكثر من مشروع
يعني المدينه داون تاون اعلن يعني في في
المدينه سيكون كذلك سفن اعلنوا مشروعهم
ووحده من شركات الصندوق اعلنوا مشروعهم
وكانت الارض كذا كذلك يعني من الامانه في
تنفيذها ومشاريع قطاع خاص اعتقد انها
كثيره وهذا الجانب برضو كذلك ينقصه الكثير
والجوانب الاخرى نعمل عليها
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
عفوا سؤال من احد الاصدقاء من سكان
المدينه يقول احنا المنطقه الوحيده اللي
ما عندنا سينما مضطر اني اسافر الى جده
عشان اشوف فيلم معقوله
نعم للاسف طبعا تاخر الموضوع هذا ما في
شيء يمنع اليوم عندنا ثلاث محظور شرعي
معين ليش ما في
طبعا تعرف تخضع الامور للعرض والطلب بشكل
او باخر اليوم في ثلاث يعني منشات مجمعات
تجاريه تحت الانشاء اعتقد خلال الاشهر
ثلاثه اربعه اشهر راح يعني تنتهي من
التنفيذ راح تبدا يعني في العمل ثلاث مشات
فيها سينما نعم
جميل بنتقل لشيء انتم كنتم نشاطين في
موضوع
الارصفه والتشجير وممرات المشاهد بس
ببداها بتغريده لناشط في مجال التصميم
الحضري في تويتر فؤاد عسيري يقول متى
تقتنع البلديات ان لفظ ممشى يعني انها
فشلت في جعل
المدينه ق المشي من خلال الشبكات ومراد
متصله واكتفت بشارع واحد يعني كانه هذا
ترجيع لمشكله اساسيه الممشى ليس دستنيشن
الواحد يروح لا عشان يمشي فيه الممشى
يفترض المدينه كلها صديقه للمشاه فبدي
تحدثني عن اول شيء قلعتك بهالملاحظه من
عدمها وتجربتكم في زياده الاماكن المشي في
المدينه المنوره انا اتفق معاه تماما
وودينا تغريدات الاخرى الخاصه بالمدينه
انا حقيقه واحده من اولى الاولويات اللي
يعني عملت عليها انه الغي اي يعني مسمى او
مشروع اسمه ممسى
لانه حقيقه هذا صحيح على هود دليل على
الفشل وما في شيء اسمه مشروع ممشى الشخص
ينبغي ان يخرج من بيته ويمشي
والامر الاخر يعني الرياض وممارسه الرياضه
ترى هذا المفترض يكون يعني هو خيار
الشياطين طبيعي انه الانسان يقضي
احتياجاته اليوميه بالمشي كيف يقدر يمشي
من 7000 الى 10,000 خطوه هذا الشيء
الطبيعي بدون ما عنده رغبه يمارس الرياضه
فهذا حقيقه تحول اللي احنا يعني اشتغلنا
عليه واللي اليوم يعني بشكل او باخر يعني
الناس تقول والله ماشي في كل مكان وكذا
الفكره كيف تطوير
الشوارع الرئيسيه
والمخططات السكنيه القائمه بانها تستوعب
هذا الجانب انه والله للشخص يخرج من بيته
يقدر يروح المدرسه يقدر يروح المسجد يقدر
يروح للمركز التجاري الوجهات اللي موجوده
في الحي بشكل امن انا ما اقصد امن يعني
ليس الامن لكن امن انه والله يحس انه
والله سلم يعني ما عنده اشكاليه كلنا من
كنا اطفال في كنا في احياء صغيره نطلع
ونروح ونيجي وكذا اليوم يطلعوا يعني ما
اعرف اذا كان ابو محمد امسك لي حاله محدده
واشرح لها بتفصيلا هذا مره صراحه وبيدغدغ
مشاعرهم اذا اعطيتنا كيس او حاله لحي
مسكتوه طورتوه وربطوه مرافق رئيسيه بممرات
مشات امنه جيد انا مات انا اتكلم لك على
يعني عندنا احياء اول شيء اول شيء
خلينا ناخذ الانواع الاحياء عندنا احياء
مخططه منظمه يعني تخطيطها حديث لكن راح
تفتقر لي بعض الجوانب الانسانيه وفي عندنا
احياء قديمه يعني عفويه او عتيقه او او
عشوائيه سماهم يعني ما تشاء في الاحياء
المخططه احنا طبعا بدانا في اولويات واضحه
كيف الحي بقربهم كثافته اللي موجوده فيه
الاحتياجات هذا ما نقدر نشتغل في كل
الاحياء مره واحده في وقت واحد واليوم
عندنا خطه واضحه لتطوير الاحياء وبدينا في
مثلا عندنا 47 حي تقريبا مخطط يعني حديث
هذه لها اولويات الان بدينا نشتغل على
سبعه او ثمانيه احياء
لتطويرها بشكل شامل يعني نتكلم على اكتمل
اكتمل الجزئيه لانه اشتغل في اكثر من حيث
عندنا حي الازهري تقدر تزوره ودي حقيقه
المره الجايه او حتى الاخوان المستمعين او
المشاهدين يعني يزورون كيف الايش المقصود
فيه في هذا ترى المقصود شيء بسيط كيف ان
الشخص يطلع من بيته يقدر يمشي بشكل امن
وهذا عندنا كذلك الخالديه حي من احياء
المدينه الكبرى
نعم اشرح لي وش سويتوا فيه
اول شيء عدد دراسه الحيه بشكل كامل من من
ناحيه عروض الشوارع ايش الاحتياج العرض
الطبيعي اللي نحتاجه من ناحيه المروريه
وكذا لانه
الشوارع ثلاث مسارات يعني ثلاث مسارات ما
تحتاج الثلاث مسارات وتلقى موقف والبيت
يعني ما حتى الشخص ما يقدر يخرج يخرج لانه
يطلع يمشي ما يستطيع الا انه يروح لهذا
يقطعه الشارع عشان واحد يروح لمركز تجاري
يعني يعتبر انه انجز انجاز لو قطع الشارع
فهذا يعني حقيقه يتنافى معه وسعنا الارصفه
كل المباني بارصفه صحيحه كيف ان الشخص
يطلع من بيته ويمشي كيف يكون في مسار
دراجات في طبعا مسار مساه مسار دراجات
تسجيل صحيح وانا قلت تسجيل صحيح هنا في
اماكن الصحيحه شجر مناسب بيئيا بشكل صحيح
ويسبق ذلك طبعا دراسه
التصريف مياه الامطار في الحي لانهم يعني
من الهدر انك تشتغل على بنيه فوقيه وتحتيه
تكون فيها اشكاليه فلذلك احيانا تاخذ وقت
في التطوير حيث هذا مثلا لو انا اليوم
ساكن فيه اطلع من بيتي اقدر امشي الى اقرب
مسجد او اقرب مدرسه
قدامي 100% لا طبعا العمل مستمر
وجود المسجد في اماكن غير هذا لكن الشخص
يقدر يمشي يروح له الى بيت جاره الى البيت
الاخر في مسار كامل للمساء فيه ممرات مشاه
يعني
ممر الدراجات نافذ توجهنا في المدينه انه
تكون فيه شبكه من يعني ما تكون
وسيله للرياضه الدراجه وسيله للتنقل واحده
من وسائل النقل الخفيفه الاساسيه هي هي
يعني الدراجه فاليوم كل الطرق الرئيسيه
شغالين على تطويرها كذلك بنفس المفهوم كيف
يكون فيه يعني مسار مساه صحيح كيف يكون في
مسار للدراجات والسكوتر الصحيح في التسجيل
في مكان الصحيح ومسار النقل العام
والحافلات كذلك يكون مهيا فهذا العمل
عندنا اكثر من 27 شارع رئيسي في المدينه
شغالين عليها يعني انجزنا تقريبا 30% الان
منها والعمل مستمر عندنا خطه واضحه
للاحياء المنظمه والمخططه خطه واضحه
اولويات واضحه للاحياء
القديمه او العشوائيه او العفويه وخطه
واضحه لتطوير الشوارع هذه راح تنتج شبكه
راح تنتج مدينه المدينه الجديده المدينه
الانسانيه القريبه من الانسان وللانسان هو
المهم فيها في في يعني يستطيع ان يتنقل
بشكل
المرحله الاولى من مشروع تطوير الاحياء
تكتمل
ما في مرحله التطوير العمراني او التخطيط
الحضري او التطوير الحضري ينبغي انه لا
ينتهي اكيد اللحظه اللي نسوي تحديث
للمنوره بانه كل احيائها اصبحت فيها موضوع
ممرات المشاه وممرات الدرجات يعني وفق
الاولويات وفق
الاولويات اللي موجوده عندنا في الاحياء
المخططه والميزانيات اللي موجوده الى الان
وخططنا فيها نتكلم عشرين 28 راح تنتهي كل
الاحياء 47 حي في 2028 تكتمل باذن الله
تعالى وش اكبر تحدي واجهتوه في الخطه انا
اليوم قاعد اتخيل انه فيه امناء مدن
قاعدين يسمعوننا او موظفين في البلديه كان
يسمعوننا خلينا نفيدهم من تجربتكم ايش
اكبر عائق صعب عليكم هذه المهمه طبعا كثير
حقيقه من الاشياء اولها زي يمكن ذكرته
باعرضا هو موضوع
البنيه التحتيه وتصريف مياه الامطار وكذا
لانه زي ما قلت لك صعب جدا اننا نروح نطور
حي وتكون في بنيه فوقيه جيده واناره جيده
وكده وعند اي مطر وكذا يكون فيه
كيف تركب المشاريع على بعض وتكون
اولوياتها يعني مع بعض هذا حقيقه واحد من
التحديات يمكن بعض الجوانب الاخرى ما هي
منطبقه في الاحياء المنظمه بشكل كبير لكن
موجوده في بعض الاحياء اكتمال البنيه
التحتيه للجهات الاخرى تكلم على الكهرباء
المياه الصرف الصحي استنى من ندرس الحي
نشوف والله هل البنيه التحتيه هذه بشكل او
باخر راح تتاثر لانه تفاجا انا مثلا طورنا
واحد من الاجزاء من جزء من حي كذا جاءت
شركه كهرباء تطلب تصريح تمدد طب هذا برضو
يشكل ليش لانه في هدر في ازاله وكذا فهنا
يجي تنسيق المشاريع في تنسيق المشاريع
الداخليه اللي تملكها الامانه وتنسيق
المشاريع الخارجيه مع الاخرين هذا واحده
من اشياء الاساسيه في الجانب او من
التحديات الاساسيه الامر الاخر قبول الناس
لهذه الفكره ان تستغرب انه يعني في في
بشكل او باخر في معارض لانه انت ضايقت
السياره مدى الجدوى من هذا ما عندك من
الارصفه مدى كذا في قبول عالي جدا اذا
انتهى المنتج يعني وهذا لمسناه وصلنا صارت
بالعكس الطلبات من شكاوي تجي للطلبات نبغى
زي الحين الفلاني نبغى تشتغلون كذا
اقتصاديات المنطقه تختلف يعني
بشكل ايجابي الانشطه تتعدل فيمكن التحديات
هذه يعني اللي اقدر اثيرها واقولها
بالاضافه الى
الدراسه دراسه الشيء سهل جدا انك تدرس
يعني منطقه مفتوحه ما فيها اي مباني
تدرسها وتنفذ عليها وهذا اليوم اكثر
الاحياء الجديده وكذا يعني تصير في هذا
الاتجاه واعتقد انه فيها كثير من عناصر
الانسنه لكن انه مدينه قائمه او حي قائم
تبدا تشتغل عليه ما تقدر تقول والله عندي
مخطط
دراسه والتصميم ورح نفذ لا يعني صعب جدا
وجدناه وكان هذا يحقق البدايه لكن كيف انه
يصير فيه اساسيات اولى او او موجهات
اساسيه وكيف نبدا نروح ننفذ على ارض
الواقع لانه في بعض المباني غير موجوده في
بعض المباني فيها بعض المخالفات المعينه
في بعض الاحتياجات اللي نشات من جهات
مختلفه تلقى يعني عمود كهرباء او شيء يعني
لخدمات مختلفه موجوده في نص الحي او في نص
الرصيف هذه كلها يعني تحتاج الى الى
تصاميم مرنه او يعني عمل مرن مصممين اعمال
مهندسين يعملون في الميدان بشكل يعني جيد
يعني ما ابالغ اذا قلت هذا هم عند
99% من المواطنين والمقيمين سالفه جوده
الشوارع وهذا لغز ما حد قادر يفهمه يعني
تحديدا تحديدا شوارع اللي تحت اشراف
البلديات والامانات يعني انا اللي فهمته
مؤخرا انه الشوارع في السعوديه تحت اكثر
من جهه ففي شوارع عنده وزاره النقل هذه
غال المدن وللامانه جودتها بالمجمل جيده
في شوارع عند ارامكو هذه غالبا تنفذها
ارامكو في منشاتها في شوارع الطيران
المدني داخل المطارات في شوارع الهيئه
الامريكيه الجبوري ينبع
اغلبهم جوده مرضيه او مرتفعه اسوا شوارع
هي شوارع البلديات شيء مخجل والله اللي
يشوف شوارعنا ما يصدقنا في السعوديه بكل
امكانياتها بكل يعني ما احبها الله سبحانه
وتعالى من يعني من من فرص وامكانيات هو
بدنا نفهم اللغز ليش ما احنا عارفين نسوي
شوارع زي العالم والناس هي طال عمرك تقول
نسوي قاعدين نسوي بشكل صحيح وزيد
بجانبين طبعا حجم حجم الشوارع مقارنه
بالجهات اللي ذكرتها كلها تختلف تماما
يعني ما عدا وزاره النقل وبين المدن وفي
العاده يعني حتى الكثافات فيها وكذا تكون
اقل
في انواع الانواع العقود طبعا هذا يقود ان
ترى للتشوه البصري بشكل او باخر انه جزء
من البصري هو الحفريات والشوارع اللي
موجوده فيها طبعا مو بعذر لكن عدم اكتمال
البنيه التحتيه لبعض الشوارع وارتفاع
المياه الجوفيه في بعضها هذا تحدي من
التحديات الرئيسيه
واحده واحده رقم واحد عدم اكتمال البنيه
التحتيه وش تقصد فيها اتكلم على تصريف
مياه الامطار مثلا في في في منطقه معينه
اتكلم على عدم وجود
الخدمات الاخرى الصرف الصحي الكهرباء
المياه تلقى كل احد يجي يبدا يحفر وينفذه
خدمه فكثره الحفريات هذه تقصر عمر الشارع
تماما السيول وعدم وجود مجالس سيول نعم
يؤثر على ارتفاع المياه الجوفيه في بعض
المناطق سواء كانت مناطق الساحليه او حتى
المناطق الغير الساحليه ويمكن حنا مثلا في
المدينه الماضيه في بعض المناطق ارتفع
ارتفعت فيها
بدت الناس تشتكي من الدخول المياه القبو
وكذا فهذا برضه يقلل من عمر الشارع موضوع
الصيانه العلاجيه والصيانه الوقائيه يعني
مفهوم الصيانه العلاجيه جاتك حفره رحت
تعالجها الصيانه الوقائيه ينبغي ان يكون
عندك رصد دائم للطريق تقول والله الطريق
الان وصل عمره كذا يحتاج اتدخل فيه كل ما
كان
في مراحل النهائيه وبدينا ناخذ امثله
ونماذج في يعني
كيف انه يتحول يتحول الصيانه الطريق تتحول
الى عقد اداء وليس به والله اليوم اقول لك
والله في عقود الصيانه تقول والله احتاج
كذا مهندس وكذا مواد وكذا وتصير يعني
الطلبات تصير مع المقاول بالطرب رح نفذ
كذا روح كان لكن كيف انك تسلم المكان او
الموقع لمقاول يصبح هو مسؤوليته بشكل كامل
ويشرف على عمل وتشغيله صيانته عندنا جانب
جانب مهم جدا تعدد
الملكيات او محتويات الطريق والملكيات
ترجع لمين اليوم الطريق 70 80% من بعض
الطرق بعض التسعين في المئه بعضها
الامانات لكن فيها عناصر موجوده لجهه اخرى
من قطع خاص او قطع حكومي اخر وكذا توصيلها
صيانتها طبعا بتقول لي الرخص موجوده عند
الامانه هي لمن ترخص الجانب هذا
كل هذا اليوم حصر الاصول مثلا حصر الاصول
اليوم مثلا قطعنا اكثر من 70% من حصر اصول
المدينه الطريق ايش فيه ايش يحتوي على ايش
مستواه لطريق الاناره العناصر الفرش
الطريق بشكل كامل عددها ملكيتها نوعها
مستواها الى اي مدى عمرها كلها هذه بتساهم
في تقليل موضوع تحسين جوده الطرق الطرق
كطريقه كعناصر فرش الطريق وكذلك في موضوع
التشوه البصري ايش المعالجه اللي انتم
اليوم تؤمنون فيها
لمعالجه الامر من جذوره متى نوصل للحظه
اللي عندنا شوارع داخل ناخذ مثال المنوره
وش المعالجه اللي وصلتوا لها وتقولون
ابشروا هذه بتعالج الموضوع بس يبي لنا وقت
قلت لك هي اكثر من جانب وهذا هو الحقيقه
اللي بيديكم
عقود الاداء نتكلم على حصر الاصول الكامل
الطريق موضوع تحسين دوره حياه التراخيص
لانشاء الخدمات المختلفه نتكلم على كذلك
تنفيذ الخدمات البنيه التحتيه بشكل متوازي
اللي هو تنسيق المشاريع اللي هو اليوم بدل
ما كل احد يشتغل في جهه من الجهات الخدميه
المختلفه لا كيف انه نركز على جانب اخر
موضوع مهم كذلك موضوع التطوير المتكامل
الاحياء او التطوير العقاري الحديث انه
كيف اطور حي كامل ببنيه التحتيه بهذا هذه
يعني في احياء موجوده في المدن اليوم
تتطور بشكل كامل ما راح تحتاج راح تكون
فيها جوده الطرق متاكد تماما راح تكون
جيده لانها ما راح يكون فيها حفر ودفن
ومستمر يعني وهل لقيت هو حل لسالفه
الحفريات المتكرره من جهات مختلفه لقيته
له حل
المحلول الان في موضوع تفعيل مكتب تنسيق
المشاريع في مكتب اسمه مكتب تنسيق
المشاريع في الامانات وكذلك دور من ادوار
الهيئات هو تنسيق المشاريع الكبرى فكيف
لتجربه في هذا الموضوع مثلا نعم عندنا
مثلا احنا اليوم عندنا في المدينه عندنا
خصخصات اعمال الرقابه على الحفريات
اطلقنا الملف هذا بشكل كامل قطع خاص اليوم
يشرف على التنسيق للحفريات ومنحه رخيص
والمراقبه عليها
والتاكد من الاغلاق بشكل بشكل صحيح اثناء
التنفيذ كيف ان المواد اللي يتم يعني
تنفيذ فيها مواد صحيحه تعرف الطبقات
التربه طبقات الاسفلت نوع الاسفلت يعني
هذا جانب مهم جدا وكيف فتره الضمان في
فتره الضمان سنتين موجوده في انك تضمن
الحفريه هذه يا مقاول منفذ او حتى شركه
يعني منفذه من الشركات الخدمه فالشريك
القطعه الخاصه على العمليه هذه كلها عند
النظام عندنا نظام اسمه نسق هو ينسق
عمليات طبعا النظام الثلاث اشهر الان
انطلق على مستوى البعض امانات المناطق وفي
المدينه يعني تحديدا هو ينسق عمليات
الحفريات كيف انه يعني تضع خطتك
المستقبليه مثل عملي شارع محدد حي محدد
ترى في حفريه يا كهرب تعالوا يا المويه
تعالوا اتصالات تعالوا الان مطلوب من كل
الشركات والامانه انها تضع خطتها
المستقبليه لعشرين 23 في النظام هذا حتى
الكل يطلع على التفاصيل في نفسها هذا يصير
خلاص انا اعرف فين التوجه توجه المشاريع
الكبرى مثلا انا جلست مثلا مع الاخوان في
شركه الكهرباء او في المياه كلها فجاه
تقول والله رخصه مكان فلان يوصل له لانه
في الاخير خدمه يعني تعرف مشروع ضخم ولا
مشروع صغير فوجود هذا النظام الان اعتقد
انه بيقلل الاشكاليات بشكل كبير ان لم
يعني يكون يعني ينفيها بشكل كامل لانه
بيصير فيه اطلاع من الشركات المختلفه على
الخدمات فين الرائحه وفين انا ينبغي اني
اوصل طبعا عندنا مثال يعني في المنطقه
المركزيه جيدا نذكره عندنا في المنطقه
المركزيه في المدينه
ما في حفر
في
عبارات خدمات موجوده يعني
بمساحات يعني كبيره جدا تتكلم على اربعه
في اربعه في اربعه يعني اعرض في طول طول
في عرض في ارتفاع
يعني فيها كل الخدمات فيها الكهرباء فيها
المياه فيها الهاتف
من اكثر من اربعين سنه الان ما في حفر في
منطقه مركزيه لذلك تجد جوده مثلا منطقه
مركزيه جودتها مرتفعه لكن تجي تقارن الاثر
الاقتصادي ويعني قيمه التنفيذ وكذا تختلف
لكن في اماكن بكثافات معينه كذا يعني قد
يكون جيد واستخدام هذا الموضوع نعم
دائما ملازم لمساله المشي والارصفه موضوع
التشجير لانه الاجواء حاره في السعوديه
عموما في المدينه خصوصا منوره الجو حار
اغلب السنه وفي ملاحظات من سكان المدينه
جتنا على موضوع انه كثير من الارصفه نفذت
بدون تشجير
ودي اعرف وش مستهدفاتكم خصوصا انه برنامج
التحول الوطني عنده
مستهدف نصيب الفرد من الساحات والاماكن
العامه
منخفض في السعوديه اقل حتى من المعدل اللي
تنصاحبه منظمات الصحه العالميه فبد اعرف
وش واقع المنوره بخصوص التشجير مسطحات
الخضراء لكل مواطن وش حققته في هذا الجانب
جيد يعني نسبه نصيب الفرد من المساحات
المفتوحه والخضراء في المدينه منخفض جدا
ولا ما في رجب
فاصله تسعه فاصله تسعه متر مربع لكل الفرد
هذا طبعا كان في 2020
احنا بدانا في الامانه باستراتيجيه راح
نتطرق لها الاستراتيجيه هذه قاست كل
العناصر الموجوده في في المدينه واللي
الامانه مسؤوله عنها وبناء عليه يعني حددت
الحاجه اللي طلعنا منها مبادرات وتفاصيل
ففي عشرين عشرين لقينا انه والله فاصله
تسعه
يعني نصيب الفرد تسعه متر مربع نصيب الفرد
في وهذا حقيقه رقم يعني خطير ويعني غير
غير مقبول ابدا
الحمد لله اليوم احنا نتكلم على اثنين
فاصل خمسه
في في في ظرف سنتين
والتوجه نصل 4.5 في عشرين اربعه وعشرين في
اليوم يعني عندنا عقود مبرمه في اعمال
يعني راح يعني تعلن في الربع الثاني من
هذا العام ان شاء الله في انشاء اربع
حدائق مركزيه نتكلم على الحديقه المركزيه
يعني مساحه كل حديقه من مليون متر مربع
شمال المدينه وشرقها وغربها واستكمال
لحديقه في حديقه عندنا واحده في الملك فهد
في الجنوب استكمال لها فهذه راح ترفع يعني
نسبه نصيب الفرد بشكل كبير جدا عندنا اكثر
من مئه حديقه حي
نتكلم على حديقه الحي ما هو في حديقه فقط
اللي ذكرت لك ربط الحديقه بالمسبل كذا
داخل الاحياء وهذا كذلك بدينا فيه يعني
بشكل
مئه حديقه نعم او مئه خلينا نسميها 100
مجاوره سكنيه اكثر من حديقه يعني حديقه
مساحتها لكن 100 مجاوره سكنيه في المنطقه
اللي جنب المسجد المنطقه اللي جنب المدرسه
المناطق هذي كلها
في 25 يعني كامله
سيبدا العمل فيها في الربع الثاني الى
الربع الثالث من هذا العام
لا لا طبعا الموضوع الاشجار والاستخدام
اليوم لو تلاحظ كل الشوارع
اللي موجوده في المدينه على الجار فيها
اشجار يعني مناسبه مناسبه بيئيا
لو تشوفوا وادي العقيق الاشجار اللي
موجوده فيه وادي قناه كلها حقيقه الاشجار
الاشجار مناسبه
للبيئه المحليه من البيئه
ريحه جيد استهلاكها المياه معقول ظلها
مناسب وبعدين طبعا في فرق بين الحديقه
وتسجيره وبين الشارع وتسجيره يعني هذه
التفاصيل الفنيه اعتقد في المدينه وتجي
تزورنا تشوف الفرق اليوم عن الزمان
والتعليقك عن موضوع الارصفه اللي لم تشجر
لا لا كلها طبعا الشجر تعرف لما تزرع شجره
تطلع في في فتره يعني قصيره
تشوف مكان الشجر موجود الري صحيح شجره
موجوده لكن وجوده ونموها الوقت
على طال الاشجار في في ملاحظه هنا على
شجره المسكيت اولا قاعد ننطقها غلط
المسكين في شجره كذا اسمها اعتقد
يشتكي يقول ضررها وفيها غازات وفي تحذير
منها لكن في اصرار من الامانه على زراعتها
وش قصتها الشجره ما اعتقد يعني الموضوع
بشكل تفصيلي لعلني اشوفه بشكل هذا لكن
كانها جاتني ملاحظه وكذا في هذا الجانب
لكن هي شجره ما استخدمتها الامانه هي شجره
وزدناها نمت في بعض الاوديه يعني كدخيله
وهذا اليوم احنا عندنا كل التطوير لكل
كامل الاوديه وتنظيفه وتحديد مساراتها
وقاعدين نتعامل معها بشكل سليم اذا كانت
هي الشجره هذه المقصوده او حتى بعض
الاشجار اللي وجدناها دخيلة حقيقه يعني
تزيلونها اعتقد انها ازيلت اذا ما كانت
ازيلت فهي طبيعي اي تدخل عندنا اليوم يعني
خبراء نباتين يعرفون محل الاشاره وطبعا
وزاره الزراعه كذلك وزاره المياه عندها ه
وهذا
وسنستشيرهم في نوع الاشجار
واماكن المحدده لها وفين نقدر نزرعها سواء
كانت في الوادي ولا في الطريق ولا في
الحديقه مربوطين وانتم بالسعوديه الخضراء
طبيعي
احنا في 2022 زرعنا 800 الف شجره يعني
اعتقد من يعني الاكبر المدن او اعلى المدن
في المملكه اللي زرع الاشجار ومتوجهين
للزراعه لكن الاهم يعني حقيقه من الزراعه
هو الري والاستدامه الزراعه هذه
فعندنا شبكه ري يعني متكامله في المدينه
وعندنا اخر مرحله منها ستنتهي في نهايه
هذا العام في نهايه 23 في نهايه 24
الاستفاده من المياه المعالجه حلو هذا
اعتقد هو يعني بدينا من
التمديد كل الشوارع والحدائق المركزيه
وكذا للاستفاده من المياه المعالجه هذا
الشيء يعني يغذي موضوع السعوديه الخضراء
والازجار والحدائق اللي ذكرت لك لان
الموضوع محوري ومهم وهذا من الجوانب اللي
تقول العمل تحت الارض احيانا يبغى له وقت
ما تنتبه له لكن الاستثمار فيه استثمار
صحيح وامثل ويحقق لك المستهدفات المختلفه
كم اليوم من المياه تعالج كرسبه
طبعا هذا ما يحضرني الرقم عند شركه عند
الاخوان في شركه المياه الوطنيه لكن يقول
والله كم المياه اللي احنا نستفيد منها
نتكلم على من واحد الى خمسه في المئه فقط
من المياه
المعاد معالجتها نستفيد منه في الاشجار
هذا اللي نحتاجه حنا يعني هذا يكفينا يعني
بعدين مع الحدائق الكبرى الاربعه هذه هذا
هذا الرقم يعني بيزيدوا ينقص عندنا مؤسسه
المؤسسه العامه للري كذلك فتحت فتحت فرع
الثاني بعد الاحساء في المدينه ومعول
عليها وبدت اليوم يعني تعمل عندهم خطط
لتغذيه المزارع وتغذيه الشوارع والاحياء
بالمياه المعالجه واعتقد ان عندهم في هذا
الجانب يعني ملف ضخم واحده من اهم ادواركم
موضوع النظافه واداره النفايات اليوم
السعوديه عندها يعني اقصد مع بدايه الرؤيه
كانت ارقام اعاده منخفضه جدا اقل من 11
12% من النفايات يعاد تدويرها والباء
والباقي تطمر في التربه بشكل ضار جدا
البيئه
والجهودكم في التعامل مع النفايات ونظافه
المدينه النظافه يعني كان عندنا تحديدا
الشركات النظافه كان عندنا شركه واحده
اصبحت الان اربع شركات يعني زياده او اربع
عقود زياده التنافسيه والعمل فيها وبشكل
يعني جيد الملف هذا ملف يعني تفصيلي في
تفاصيل كثيره جدا حقيقه وفي فرص تطوير
وفيه عدد من الجهات اليوم اللي تعمل عليه
ما هو فقط الامانه عندنا المركز الوطني
النفايات عندنا سيرك عندنا كذا حنا في
المراحل النهائيه
لعقد شراكه انشاء شركه مختصه بالنفايات مع
احد الشركاء القطاع
الخاصيه شركه المقر الذراع الاستثماري
للامانه يعني شريك فيها شركه سيرك وشريك
من القطاع الخاص لاداره عمليات لاعاده
التدوير بشكل بشكل كامل عندنا مردم
الامانه مردم يعني جيد ونموذجي يعمل بشكل
جيد غير مرضي لكنه يعمل بشكل بشكل جيد
اليوم نقصد من الشركه انها تقود هذا عمليه
التحول بشكل كامل حتى يعني نصل لمستويات
المطلوب بس ما بدات لسه في المراحل
النهائيه يعني في المراحل النهائيه
للانشاء الشركه واعلانها
اتذكرك تسولف مع واحد مسؤول في في وزاره
البلديات يقول لي كنت اقول بقابل امين
المدينه
فقل لي غششني سؤال اساله اياه قال
حنا اي مبادره تخصيص
ويشيلونها ويشيلونها فهم سابقين الكل في
موضوع التخصيص فهو سر حماسكم التخصيص وايش
اهم تحقق في تخصيص الخدمات خصوصا انه معي
الوزير يعني في لقائه معنا الصقرات وفي
اكثر من من مكان كان يؤكد بانه مشروع
الاوضح
والاكبر في البلديات هو تخصيص 70% من
الخدماتها
في موضوع التخصيص
درسنا حنا اول شيء موضوع التخصيص اعتقد
انه يعني مهم جدا جدا باهميه التوسع في
الخدمات وكذا يمكن التوسع في المدن بشكل
او في المدينه يعني تحديدا التوسع الكبير
والمتطلبات المختلفه يدعونها يعني والوضوح
الشفافيه يعني ننشد حقيقه الوضوح ننشد
الشفافيه السرعه التنفيذ الاعمال وتمكين
الاعمال كلها
وسهوله تنفيذ الاعمال يعني اليوم المدينه
نحاول انه
يؤدي فيها العمل يقول والله بديت بشكل
سريع رخصتي بشكل سريع في وضوح الشفافيه في
الاجراءات المختلفه انا بذكر لك مثال على
التخصيص وبعدين باقي الملفات احنا مثلا
بدينا في تخصيص الرقابه على المحلات
التجاريه
الصحيه وهذا كان حقيقه واحد من الاشياء
اللي كانت مؤرقه بالنسبه لي شخصيا
وكان كثير من المراجعين
يشتكون يشتكون من هذا الجانب تحديدا تعرف
رائد اعمال ولا شركه ولا كذا ولا هذا تجي
بغرامه اغلاق مدري فين
يوم من الايام جاتني السيده قالت انا عندي
مطعم جاني مراقبكم قال احط بدت هذا قاعد
تحط الموصل هنا وحطي كذا هنا وحطي هنا
يعني ونفذت بناء على رايه جاني الزياره
واحد ثاني في الزياره الثانيه قلت مين قال
لك لا هذه هنا وهذه هنا فالدين ايش تبغون
انا مستعده بس اعطني كان حقيقه هذا واحد
من التحديات الرئيسيه طب من جيت ادخل فيه
الا والله يعني وجدت انه ملف يحتاج يعني
تطوير حتى خلينا نكون يعني اكثر اكثر دقه
يعني ينبغي ان نركز عليه لانه يساهم بشكل
او باخر في تمكين العمل
لشركات رواد اعمالي كذا
اشتغلنا على اكثر من جانب التخصيص اليوم
لونه نسميها هي رحله تحول في التخصيص كيف
المدرسه التشريعات
الخاصه بهذا الملف بشكل كامل درسنا كل
التشريعات الخاصه بموضوع الرقابه طورنا
قوائم تدقيق يعني عندنا اليوم اكثر من 157
قائمه تدقيق
محل مطعم وجبات سريعه يختلف عن مطعم مندي
يختلف عن مطعم بخاري قائمه تدقيق واضحه
ليش لانه بيكون هذا هو العلاقه بيننا وبين
شركه قطعه الخاصه انا ادقق على هذه وانت
ينبغي انك تنتبه له اذا خلف يعني يصبح
اصبح يحق له انه يخالفني خارج هذا القائمه
نعم فقام موجوده ومنشوره يستطيع بل حتى
الان بدينا يعني نطلب من المنشات ان هي
تقيم نفس قبل يجيك المراقب قيم نفسك وقول
والله
انا ملتزم ولا غير ملتزم وهذه قوائم
التدقيق يمكن طورناها الان من سنه وشغالين
على تطويرها بشكل مستمر ونطلع قائمه
التدقيق
للمنشات الجديده او الانشطه الجديده هذا
جانب مهم كان كيف ان الشخص يقيم نفسه
ذاتيا الامر الاخر كادر البشري من الكادر
البشري لقينا والله العدد والمعرفه
والاستثمار فيه والاجهزه يعني كانت
الامانه تقوم فيه بشكل ذاتي ومرهق يعني
وما فيه حياديه وما في كذا يعني صعب جدا
فتعرف الاجهزه الخاصه بهذا الشيء
الاستثمار فيها توريدها صيانتها تشغيلها
بعدين مين اللي يحكم فيها والعدد
شفنا الشركاء قطع الخاص متخصصين في هذا
الجانب تعاقدنا مع احدهم
يعني يقوم بتوفير الكوادر البشريه المدربه
ويشرف على تدريبه وتاهيلهم بشكل مستمر
اليوم عندنا اكثر من 70 مراقب ومراقبه
يعني من ابناء البلد يشرفون على العمليه
هذه
الامر الاخير او الاخر هو كيف انه يكون
فيه يعني ما نبدا بالوحده من الاشياء
التشريعات وكذا ما نبدا بالغرامه جوانب او
ملاحظات بسيطه جدا لتمس صحته سلامه الناس
هي اللي تبدا بغرام او حتى اغلاق المحل
فيما بعد ذلك تبدا بالانذار بالاشعار
العامه المره الاولى والثانيه او كذا فهذا
برضو جانب تشريعي يرتبط بتطوير التدريب
بالاشخاص وعندنا الاداه التقنيه ممتثل
اليوم برنامج الكتروني واضح الشخص يقيم
نفسه ذاتيا يجي المراقب يتاكد من التدقيق
هذا بشكل بشكل يعني دوري
اول ما يطلع المراقب تجي للمنشاه رساله
فيها نتيجه الزياره وفيها تقييم للعمليه
الرقابيه وتقييم المراقب والمراقب طبعا
قيم المنشاه فتنتج لك يعني نتيجه مركبه
بين بين الاثنين هذه وضحت لنا ان والله او
صار في وضوح صار في شفافيه عاليه طيب
الاعتراض
بعض الملاحظات او بعض الغرامات في ينتج
عنها اعتراض صاحب المنشاه يعترض اوكلنا
هذه المهمه كذلك لطرف ثالث متخصص في اداره
عمليات الاعتراضات بامكانك اول ما تجيك
رساله بالاعتراف تعترض تروح
الطرف الثالث يقيم يقول والله فيه فعلا
الملاحظه الصحيحه وغير صحيحه وبناء عليه
اذا كان الصحيحه تستمر غير صحيحه تحاسب
الشركه القطع الخاص وتخصم قيمه الزياره
لهذا الامر الهام كذلك انه اصبحت اليوم
بعد بعد مسيره 11 شهر
طورنا المفهوم الى
اداره المخاطر اكثر من اداره المخاطر اكثر
من زياره دوريه كيف اليوم المنشات اللي
اتضح فيها يعني اتضحت انه ممتثله او
ملتزمه اقلل الزيارات فيها اليوم عندنا
منشات نزورها مره واحده في السنه
والعكس في منشات نزورها بشكل مكثف الى
درجه بعض المنشات كل ثلاث اسابيع نزورها
اذا اتضح انه والله هو غير غير ملتزمه
والامتثال عندها منخفض فهذه اصبح عندنا
يعني مرونه في الاوسعه عقدا عقد اداء
مرونه في الاعداد الطلاع تشجيع الامتثال
حتى مفهوم الرقابه الان يعني بدينا نقلله
ما في شيء اسمه رقابه هو تشجيع الامتثال
وامتثال جانب اخير اللي هو موضوع
التوعيه والتدريب الصحي اليوم في مركز خاص
بالتدريب العاملين في المنشات هذه المقهى
المطعم التفاصيل هذه كلها لابد انه
العمالي موجودين فيه يخضعون لدوره تدريبيه
يومين الى خمس ايام نظري وعملي حتى يعني
نشجع الامتثال ويكون في امتثال عالي هذا
رفعنا من امتثال من 60% الى 80% في 11 شهر
عندنا 80% من المنشات في المدينه يعني
ممتثره وعمليه التطوير ما زالت مستمره في
هذا الجانب هذا فقط في تخصيص يعني جزء
بسيط لكنه كان حقيقه
ادوار الرقابه نعم في هذه مجموعه اسئله جت
فقال ما نغادروا الامثله الثانيه استاذنك
اني اطرحها عليك هذا يقول
الشركه الخاصه بالرقابه عن محلات التجاريه
تقيم المحلات التجاريه ضعيف مقبول الى اخ
بدون ان يكون هناك اختار لصاحب المحل
اسبابها التقييم واليه عمل التقييم وطريقه
تحسين التقييم من قبل صاحب المنشاه يمكن
هذا في البدايه الان لا يعني في البدايات
النظام الالكتروني كذا الان اول ما يخرج
المراقب تجي رساله سواء كان بريد الكتروني
او حتى رساله على الجوال كذا وهذه الاسباب
وهذه الاسباب وحتى في ممتثل لك ملف تقييمك
كذا وهذه الاسباب وهل انتم موافق او لا
وكيف انت اليوم تقيم المراقب تقيم العمليه
الرقابيه حلو يعني اليوم انتم تعلمونه ليش
تقييموا منخفض جميل سؤال ثاني يقول تقوم
الشركه الخاصه بالرقابه على المحلات بفرض
غرامات التجاريه ولا يتم تزويد اصحاب
محلات باليات ومسبات هذا الغرام او
اعطائهم تقرير يمكنهم اطلع عليه لتلاع في
هذه الملاحظات حتى لا يتم فرض غرامات
عليهم مجددا
الاعتزال مشكله موجوده مرتبطه طبعا
بالملاحظه الاولى وكذلك الموضوع قوائم
التدقيق اليوم الرقابه الذاتيه اصلا حتى
جالسين الان ندرس كيف انه نجبر على رقابه
الذاتيه ينبغي انك تسوي ندرسها من ناحيه
ينبغي اذا انت رقبت نفسك عرفت انتهت
العمليه يمكن ما احتجت اصلا بس اليوم هل
في غرامات بدون تسبيب
اخر سؤال في الجزئيه عند مراجعه اصحاب
المحلات او للاعتراض على التقييم
يتم احالتهم للشركه الخاصه بالرقابه
والشركه تحيرهم الى موقع بلدي والنتيجه لا
اجابه عند الجميع فاين اذهب الناس
هذا طبعا كلفنا الان اداره عمليه
الاعتراضات وقياسها الى شركه حتى نضمن
الحياديه للشركه ولا القطاع ولا حتى
الامانه شريك متخصص في اداره الاعتراضات
كيف انه يقيس احيانا مكتبي واحيانا عندما
ترى جزء من الاعتراضات تقبل يمكن الاغلب
تقبل
مو لانه ما في ملاحظه لانه كان ينقص مثلا
المراقب اداه معينه او مده الزياره عندنا
حتى مده الزياره محدده حتى ادنى كذا مده
الزياره كذا الهدف في في المنظومه هذه
والعمليه هذه حقيقه هو رفع الامتثال ما هو
الهدف يعني الغرامه وكذا بل حتى العقد مع
الشركه عقد اداء تحفيزي كل ما المنشات
امتثلت كل
يوم مو هدفه ولا هدف نحقق انه يكون فيه
يعني الغرامات ولا رقبات هدف كيف انه
نحافظ على صحه سلامه الناس ونمكن الاعمال
انها تقوم فيها هذا كان نموذج للتخصيص
اللي هو موضوع تخصيص الرقابه وتمكيل
الاعمال زي ما انت تسميها نبغى نسمع امثله
ثانيه في التخصيص طبعا حصرنا كل العمليات
اللي موجوده تقوم فيها الامانه سواء كانت
في الرقابات او في تمكين الاعمال او حتى
في الجوانب الاخرى واليوم عندنا برنامج
واضح للتخصيص
مثلا مثال المختبر الاغذيه نفس الشيء
وجدنا انه الامانه عندها يعني مختصين في
الاغذيه وعندها ادوات وتستثمر في هذه
الادوات وتجيبها وصيانتها ومعي وكذلك يعني
هذا الجانب يعني مرهق فيه يعني هدر للوقت
وهدر للجهود وكذلك ما في حياديه يعني مين
اللي يقول اليوم انه فعلا هذا الشيء هذا
كذلك الان المختبر الاغذيه يعني راح مع
شركه المقر الذراع الاستثمار الامانه شركه
المقر تعاقدت مع شريك متخصص او انشات
شراكه مع متخصص في اداره المختبرات
الاغذيه وبدا يعمل الان كذلك من سته اشهر
في اداره العمليه هذه حقيقه ولاحظنا انه
في كفاءه في الانفاق كفاءه في التشغيل
حياديه في الطرح وكذلك يعني اصبحت الامانه
مشرفه وارتحنا من موضوع الاجهزه وتوريدها
ومعاييرتها وتفاصيلها هذا جانب ذكرت لك
كذلك موضوع
الاسراف على الحفريات او او
التوصيل الخدمات كذلك الان في عندنا شريط
قطع خاص وقعنا معاه وبدا ينزل الان في
اداره العمليه هذي بشكل متكامل يمكن اللي
ذكر لك اياه زميلنا في الوزاره صحيح لانه
اعتقد انه هذا الملف يعني مهم جدا يمكن
الامانه انها ترجع يعني تمارس دورها
الحقيقي في الاسراف في التمكين وفي العمل
وكذلك مواضيع الكفاءه الانفاق وكفاءه
التشغيل والحياديه والوضوح فرص العمل اللي
قاعده تنتج من هذا كله حقيقه يعني برضو
يعني محفزه ومشجعه لكن تسولف مع احد سكان
المدينه قلت له اليوم المملكه كل مدنها
قاعده يعاد بناء استراتيجياتها على
المزايا النسبيه وعلى كل مدينه ايش تميز
فيه عشان ما يكررون بعض ويتنافسون
تتذكر فتره الماضيه كان مثلا في مشروع ل
12 وادي تقنيه في 13 منطقه مناطق المملكه
وهذا ما هو صحيح يعني مستحيل كلهم متميزين
في التقنيه اليوم لا التركيز على
الاستراتيجيه لكل منبثقه بالمزاياها فسالت
هذا الساكن في المدينه قلت له انت من اهل
المدينه مش مزايا المدينه وش الشيء اللي
تعتقد انك تتمنى تشوفه في المدينه
وحيميزها عن بقيه المملكه كان احنا عندنا
ثلاث مزايا رقم واحد بطبيعه الحال وهو
معروف الحرم النبوي الشريف
والتراث الاسلامي والاثار الاسلاميه فاحنا
نتكلم على فرصه سياحيه هائله الى اليوم لم
تشتغل فبدي اسمع منك في موضوع اختصاص
كومنتون تطوير المواقع التاريخيه والمواقع
الاسلاميه والتراثيه لتهيئتها للزيار
واستقطاب السياح رقم اثنين يقول احنا
عندنا كميه غير ناطقين بالعربيه مهوله
وكلهم يبغى يتعامل عربي فاحنا نقدر نكون
رواد تعليم اللغه العربيه لغير العرب
فهذا ايضا ودي اسمع ايش صار فيه نقطه
ثالثه مره حبيتها صراحه كان اتكلم على انه
اليوم
السياحه الاستشفائيه او او السياحه
العلاجيه هذه
منتشره والناس تروح تسافر الهند عشان تقعد
في منتجع يوجا يقعد له فتره استشفاء ذهني
وعلاجي وواحد يروح للاسبانيا يقعد له في
منتجع استشفى يقول احنا عندنا المدينه
المنوره اللي الناس بمجرد ما تدخل كلهم
يكررون نفس العباره يا اخي احس براحه
نفسيه احس براحه نفسيه لكن ما في ولا
منتجع واحد استشفائي
استجمامي يستطيع الواحد يروح له
ويقضي في فتره استشفاء نفسي او روحي او او
جسدي او حتى برنامج
غذائي معين
فهذه الثلاثه كمزايا نسبيه للمدينه اول
شيء هل تتفق معها واذا ايه وش بتسوون في
كل ميزه من هذولي اتفق تماما مع الثلاث
مزايا المدينه منوره زي ما ذكرت لك يعني
مدينه عريقه
ما يعني كل شبر فيها حقيقه
احنا عندنا باحثين تاريخيا كل ما رحنا
نطور مكان نقول والله تعال ادينا لهذا الا
في قصه ولا حديث ولا تشريع ولا كذا فهذه
ميزه من حقيقه مميزات المدينه
المدن او المدينه تحديدا في
مدينه مباني ومدينه معاني مدينه المباني
اللي يسكن هامليون ونصف شخص ويعني تفاعلوا
معها ويزورها كذا مدينه معانى اللي مرتبطه
باكثر من مليار مسلم يعني ينظروا لها
ويزلونها ويسعون للوصول لها وكذا وتؤثر
بشكل او باخر على على يعني مستوى الاسلامي
وعلى المستوى الانساني
موضوع المواقع التاريخيه واحده من اميز
الميز النسبيه
للمدينه المسجد النبوي الشريف هو الاساس
وهو يعني المرجع لكن عندنا حصرنا اكثر من
2000 موقع
التاريخ اسلامي او طبيعي في المدينه منطقه
مدينه المنطقه المدينه
يعني محصوره موثقه مؤكده طب بنشتغل في
الالفين لا طبعا يعني فيها فيها يعني لابد
ان يكون في اولويات واضحه للعمل تم تحديد
المئه موقع اللي داخل نطاق العمراني
بالاضافه الى موقع من المواقع خارج نطاق
المراني بتكلم عنه الان
قلنا انه هذه لابد انه يتم تطويرها
وتفعيلها في فرق بين التطوير والتفعيل
تطوير التفعيل هو المطلوب وهو كيف ان
الشخص يجي يزور يجد قصه يجد مرشده يعني
ارشادات يستمتع في انشطه متعدده حاليا
حددنا المئه موقع بدانا في العمل فيها
في تطويرها وتفعيلها طبعا اقول والله
حددنا وكذا في منظومه لهذا العمل في اكثر
من جهه وهذه من مزايا الرؤيه انه الجهات
كلها تعمل بشكل واضح واحد
اجتماعاته اجتماعاتنا دوريه حل الاشكاليات
عندنا وزاره الثقافه وهيئه التراث عندنا
السياحه
ضيوف الرحمن وزاره الحج وزاره شؤون
الاسلاميه الاوقاف كذلك عندها بعض المواقع
وهيئه التطوير والامانه كلنا حقيقه نعمل
عندنا اجتماعات شهريه لهذا الجانب كل مين
يقوم بدوره تعرف الادوار موقع التاريخيه
ملكيه الموقع جهه الوصول للموقع هذا دور
الامان ودور الهيئه
التسويق للموقع وكذا نهايه السياحه فكيف
الادوار هذه تكون متكامله هذا هذا الملف
اللي شغالين عليه حددنا المئه موقع الاولى
العشرين منها الان منتهيه عشرين موقع من
المياه منتهيه متى 25 20 25
الهدفون الميه تخلص مهيئه
فيها احتياجات الاساسيه كلها تكلم على
موقف مكان لوحه توثيق الجوانب الاساسيه
وبعضها ننتقل فيها العنصر الابهار كيف
تكون فيها يعني عناصر اضافيه مبهره عروض
صوت
مناسبه للمكان فهذا الملف اعتقد واحد من
ملفات المهمه واللي يميز المدينه واللي
اليوم احنا اليوم ترى المدينه
يعني من اعلى المدن زياره في العالم نتكلم
على 21 22
والعدد هذا قاعد بيزيد لانه المستهدف 30
مليون في عشرين ثلاثين
كعدد
جيد وقاعد يزيد لكن كمده بقاء واستمتاع
وكذا لا منخفض فالعنصر
المواقع التاريخيه اثراء تجربتهم مهم
الجانب الاخر جانب اللغه العربيه انا امس
كنت اكلم
سمو رئيس الجامعه الاسلاميه
على هذا طبعا من فتره بس يعني لنا فتره
يعني هم حقيقه عندهم معهد متخصص لتعليم
اللغه العربيه لغير الناطقين بها
وفي عمل كبير في هذا الجانب يعني في في
كيف انه يفعلونه وهم مفعل عندهم وبداوا
يسوقون كنت اتكلم معاه على كيف انه نبدا
نشتغل مع هيئه السياحه والجهات الاخرى
انها يعني تسوق هذا الجانب واذا كان في
جوانب اخرى اضافيه تعرف انه الطالب يجي طب
فين يسكن فين يروح كذا انا مثلا في
اليابان واحد من اصدقائي كان يعني تكلم
اللغه العربيه
استغربت انه درس مثلا في في دول يعني حتى
لغتها العربيه يعني ضعيفه
فهذا جانب يعني نستطيع ان نستثمر فيه
استثمار كبير جدا بالاضافه الى عندنا معهد
خاص وعندنا كذلك جامعه طيبه عندها معهد
البحوث والدراسات قاعدين يطورون هذا
الجانب ويستثمرون فيه فهذا جانب مهم كذلك
يعني ينبغي انه نهتم فيه اهتمام كبير وفي
بوادر له الجانب الاخير جانب
مستشفى
مرتبط تماما بالسكينه المدينه فيها
السكينه وهذا وحده من الميز اللي موجوده
فيها فكيف انه تكون
المراكز الاستشفائيه المختلفه سواء كانت
العلاج العلاج الطويل المدى العلاج
للرعايه النهائيه الرعايه الاصابات
الحوادث الجوانب هذه كلها اليوم عندنا
شركه المقر لذراعي استثماري للامانه عندها
واحد من المشاريع المميزه لمركز استشفائي
تم التوقيع واعلن قبل فتره متوقع انه في
2028 يعني يشتغل المرحله الاولى وتنتهي
تنتهي منه كذلك
اعاده تاهيل
التغذيه صحيه الجوانب الادمان لبعض
الاشياء وكذا علاج الادمان بالاضافه الى
انه فيه اكثر من يعني عمل سيعلن قريبا في
تنسيق لهذا الجهود سواء كان من وزاره
الصحه من
مدينه الامير سلطان الطبيه والقطعه الخاص
في هذا الجانب فاعتقد انه جانب مهم جدا
بالاضافه الى انه كيف تكون المدينه يعني
وجهه
للتقاعد او وجهه
للبيت الثاني
لمسنا انه نحققه في ناس كثير تجري تتقاعد
في المدينه وفي ناس تسعى يكون عندها بيت
ثاني في المدينه فهذا الجانب مهم كيف انك
توفر احتياجات والخيارات المناسبه وكيف
انك تسوقها وتستفيد من الفرصه الاقتصاديه
الكبيره هذه بنتقل لابو محمد بمجموعه
بمناسبه الاصدقاء يعني اختم فيها اللقاء
الثري
فينا سؤال على موضوع بلغ عدد الاحياء
المستهدفه في تطوير 14 حي ولم يتم
الافصاحا ماهيه التطوير هل هي ازاله او
تطوير او ماذا هذا الامر اربك السوق
العقاري بهذه الاحياء
اربك السوق العقاري بهذا الاحياء التي
تمثل جل مساحه المدينه بيعا وشراءا
وتاجيرا فهل يفصح عن ماهيه التطوير المزمع
بهذه الاحياء
طبعا ذكرنا احنا في يعني انتشرت الاشاعه
هذه وذكرنا فيها انه الهدف من التطوير
سواء كان الاحياء المنظمه او غير المنظمه
نطلب حنا احيانا بعض المستندات وبعض لهدف
تطوير وانسنه الاحياء ليس بهدف يعني
في وقتها وفيها وضوح شفافيه عاليه لكن هي
الهدف كيف انه نطور الاحياء هذه
بغرض معرفه الملكيات التفاصيل كيف نقدر
نستفيد من المساحات المفتوحه المساحات
يعني
تملكها الدوله في هذا الجانب سواء كان
مدارس مراكز صحيه اراضي مخصصه وغيره سؤال
هنا على موضوع الطرق الرئيسيه المهمه
بالمدينه تم عمل الكبري لها او نفق لا
زالت تعاني الاشارات المروريه بها من
الاختراق وذلك بسبب قله المخارج والمداخل
على الكوبري او النفق فهل في حلول
طبعا الحلول نعم اليوم عندنا اكثر من عشره
تقاطعات تحت الانشاء في وقت واحد وهذه
يعني احنا قاعدين عندنا يعني رصد
لملاحظات المواطنين والسكان وكذا يشتكون
كثير من الملاحظات الايجابيه اللي تجينا
كثير هي حقيقه في عندنا مشاريع تطوير
الطرق وتطوير التقاطعات في وقت واحد عندنا
عشره تقاطعات قاعده تطور في وقت واحد كلها
ستنتهي هذه السنه يعني كل العشره في نهايه
هذا العام ان شاء الله بحول الله تنتهي
وعندنا الحزمه الجديده ان شاء الله كذلك
في السنتين القادمه تنفيذها هذه كلها
بترفع من مستوى
المروريه او او الجوده جوده الطرق من جوده
الطرق وكذلك موضوع الوصول والوصوليه وربط
المدينه بشكل جيد بالنسبه للازالات التي
تقوم بها البلديه وهيئه التطوير لماذا
التعويض عيني بدلا من نقدي لانه كما كان
معه سابقا لانه التعويض النقدي لا يوفر
لنا البديل المناس طبعا في خيار فيه كل
الخيارين موجوده
تعويض العيني في النظام موجود والتعويض
النقدي موجود والخيار للمالك وليس يعني
النظام التعويض العيني يقول والله انه
لابد ان المالك هو يعني يوافق على هذا
الجانب فكلاهما موجود فالخيار له المعوض
لماذا لا يتم منح اصحاب العقارات المزارع
مهله كافيه قبل اعلان ازاله جميع اعلانات
الازاله لم تبلغ المده بها شهر من الاعلان
حتى قطع الكهرباء والماء وهذا ارعب الناس
وهي مده غير كافيه البحث عن السكن اخر
معقول اعطيتهم بس شهر واحد يعني ما اعتقد
انه نحتاج نعرف بالضبط المشروع طبعا ما في
ازالات ضخمه ما عدا بعض المشاريع البسيطه
وبعدين اصلا نظام واضح في هذا الجانب يعني
يعني يعطي صلاحيه واضحه له او يحدد صلاحيه
الامانه في هذا وقرر من الوزراء الاخير
اعتقد نظم المساله هذه انه لا يمكن انه
هذا الا انه يستلم تعويضه وكل الجانب
فالجانب التعويض ونزع الملكيه جانب يعني
محدد مؤطر بانظمه ما اعتقد في احد يستطيع
انه يعني يتجاوزها بعض الاحياء يسبح لها
ببناء الجدار الصامت وبعض الاحياء لا يصبح
رغم انها مجاوره لبعض ليش ما يتم التوحيد
من مبدا الى الاعداد والمساواه والله احنا
بموضوع البناء بالصامت والبناء وارتفاعات
كل هذا اليوم قاعد يدرس لانه يعني اعتقد
في فرصه تطوير عاليه جدا
المركزيه في اتخاذ قرار يعني في التخطيط
وكل المخططات مشابهه وكل كذا يعني يفقدنا
التنوع المنظم
احنا سابقا كان عندنا تنوع
وبعدين في بعض الاحياء الجديده الان في
تنظيم
التنوع تشوه بصري والتنظيم ممل فكيف يكون
في تنوع منظم هذا حقيقه الخلطه اللي اليوم
سواء كانت الاحياء القائمه بعضها فيها فرص
او حتى الاحياء الجديده
شعر ابو محمد على موضوع شركه المقر وش
قصتها وش دورها شركه المقر هو الذراع
الاستثماري للامانه المدينه
نعمل اليوم حقيقه في الشركه على يعني
تشجيع الاستثمارات في المدينه تعزيز جوده
الحياه عندنا عدد يعني كبير من المشاريع
اللي اعلنا عنها الفتره الماضيه وبعدد من
المشاريع التي نعلن عنها استطعنا حقيقه
جذب رؤوس اموال جيده نوع وكم الكم مهم لكن
كذلك النوع
هدفنا الرئيسي هو فيها تعزيز جوده الحياه
في المدينه جذب
التجار او رؤوس الاموال الجيده لقطاعات لم
تكن موجوده في المدينه وكذلك موضوع
الاستدامه الماليه تحقيق الاستدامه
الماليه للامانه الان زي ما تعرف انه
الامانات او الامانه مسؤوله عن تشغيل
وصيانه المدينه تشغلوا صيانه المدينه من
فين يجي من الايرادات المختلفه لشركه
المقر عندنا اليوم مشاريع سكانيه مميزه
يعني اعلنا عنها ووقعناها عندنا مدينه
لوجستيه عندنا كذلك مشروع ترفيهي ثقافي
جيد
فبدات الشركه تنشط وتعمل في هذا الجانب
رؤوس اتكلم تقريبا اربعه مليار مشاريع
اللي تم تم الاعلان عنها وتوقيعها الان
تقريبا 4 مليار ريال ايراداتها راح تكون
يعني حافز كبير للامانه لتحقيق الاستلام
الماليه في 27 28 ومن بعد ذلك
والعلاقه تكون انه انتو توفرون الارض
والمستثمر يوفر التمويل والتشغيل
وتتقاسمون للدخل طبعا اكثر من نموذج في
نموذج
الشراكه الشراكه تنسى شركه خاصه بالمشروع
فيه تاجير المباشر في لا والله التاجير
المباشر مع الشراكه بالايراد في اكثر من
نموذج في هذا الجانب على حسب حاله كل
مشروع عندنا واحد من المشاريع اللي مرتبط
بالانسنه بشكل او باخر نذكر مثلا
زي ما قلت لك انا والله كيف انه نحول
الدراجه الى وسيله تنقل مو وسيله رياضه
وهي وسيله رياضه لكن تفسير وسيله التنقل
فكنا نبحث عن عن شركه متميزه في هذا
الجانب استطاعت المقر انها تعقد شراكه مع
شركه كريم اليوم كريم بايك بتكون اول عمل
لهم في المملكه في المدينه لتوفير اكثر من
سبعين يعني محطه تنقل يستطيع الشخص يركب
الدراجه او السكوتر في المدينه في مسارات
المحدده والامنه وكذا هذا مثال بسيط
للشراكه يعني لجذب شركه متخصصه في مجال
معين لهدف محدد بالاضافه الى عندنا مشاريع
مع اكثر من من شركه متميزه في قطاع
الاسكان لتوفير سكن يعني
مستوى اخر من سكن السكن الجيد او فوق
الجيد او الفاخر في المدينه لانه هذا
الجانب لاحظناه في شركه في الشركه انه
يعني ينقص المدينه فهذه كلها الجوانب تعمل
عليها المقر بالاضافه الى عندنا اذا سمعت
عنهم يعني ملتقى استثماري لمشاريع المدينه
الهدف منه انه بدا في المدينه والهدف منه
يعني يتجول في المملكه وبعض مدن العالم
المهتمه بالاستثمار في المدينه توفير كذلك
البيانات العقاريه المختلفه في المدينه
اليوم في تقرير شهري ينشر من المقر لتوفير
البيانات العقاريه لتمكين التجار
والمستثمرين فانهم يعرفون اتجاهات العقار
في المدينه بالاضافه الى امر اخير عندنا
ديوانيه المقر ديوانيه شهريه مفتوحه للجذب
رواد ورائدات الاعمال اصحاب القرار
المختلفين اللي يساهمون في دعم وتنميه
المدينه هذا واحد من مبادرات التي تعمل
عليه المقر اليوم جميل موضوع الاوقاف
المدينه مشهوره بالاوقاف وكثير موقوفين
اشترت في التعامل مع هذا الموضوع عندنا
عدد كبير من اراضي الاوقاف في المدينه
وعندنا حقيقه حراك كبير مع الاخوان في
الاوقاف لتنميتها وتفعيلها خدمه المدينه
الشيء الجيده انه كثير من الاوقاف هذه
المزارع وتعرف يعني
واحد من ميزه المدينه هي وجود المزارع
والنخيل في المدينه فهذا الجانب يعني مهم
اليوم نعمل على الاستفاده من الاراضي هذه
والمقر قاعد تقوم بدور مع شركه الاوقاف
وكذلك الامانه في التمكين الاراضي في يعني
تحديد الانشطه المناسبه
الوقف او تحديد الارض وكيف اننا نقدر
نستفيد منها موضوع القطاع الثالث
القطاع الثالث حقيقي قطاع مهم جدا وجدنا
انه من تحقيق الاستدامه الماليه للامانه
انه كيف نسند بعض العمليات والاعمال لقطع
الثالث اللي هو يعني يقوم فيها بشكل جيد
ويضمن استدامتها ويضمن انها تعمل بشكل جيد
عندنا مثالين يمكن بعرج عليها بشكل سريع
عندنا جمعيه البقيع ونشات
من اشهر لاداره عمليات اكرام الموتى كيف
هذا الدور كان تقوم بشكل كامل جيد كان
العمل فيه يعني بشكل جيد لكن وجدنا انه قد
يكون في فرصه تطوير كبيره جدا اذا القطاع
الثالث يعني اسندت المهمه له انشانا
لجمعيه البقيع بدات تستلم الاعمال
التدريجيا زي ما ذكرت لك الهدف كيف انه
يكون فيه كل سلسله القيمه في
العمليات اكرام الموتى تسند للشركه من
يعني النقل الى
هذا بل حتى رحنا للعناصر اخرى اضافيه
موضوع المواساه
والدعم في العزاء وكذلك الدعم الاجتماعي
والدعم النفسي لمن يحتاج من الجانب هذا
فهذا حقيقه
اعطانا يعني
هدوء شويه في الملف هذا اللي قاعدين نشتغل
عليه حنا الى ان ينتقل الجمعيه بشكل كامل
تعمل عليه وترفع من الكفاءه ويحقق
مستهدفات مختلفه في السوان الماليه او
كفاءه التشغيل على المثال هذا مثال المثال
الاخر عندنا جمعيه مراكز الاحياء جمعيه
مراكز الاحياء مجلس ادارتها صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير فيصل بن سلمان وانا ابو
الامير سعود بن خالد الفيصل يعني ينوب
نائب رئيس المجلس
مهمتها حقيقه تعزيز الاواصل الاجتماعيه في
الاحياء
وجدنا انه عندنا اكثر من 70 ملعب مثلا
انشاتها الامانه وقدره على تشغيلها
وصيانتها وكذا كانت محدوده وكانت كثير
حقيقه من الملاحظات تجيني على هذا الجانب
يعني الملاعب مهجوره ما فيها اناره كيف
تشغيلها مين يستغلها مين يشتغلها
فاسندت العمليه هذه لجمعيه مراكز الاحياء
اليوم اكثر من 70 ملعب تعمل يعني بكفاءه
عاليه جدا
في كثير من الاكاديميات نشات الاكاديميات
الرياضيه نشات من هذه الملاعب فيك قدام
اللاعبين وجدنا بعض قدام اللاعبين في
المدينه صار هم يديرون الملاعب هذه بعض
الملاعب او القطاع الخاص يديرها بشكل جيد
في تطبيق الكتروني تحجز الملعب في اوقات
محدده تستطيع انك تستمتع فيه ويعني تستفيد
منه ويعني راح عنك كاهل الامانه موضوع
صيانتها وتشغيلها بشكل صحيح وجيد الامر
الاخر موضوع مجالس الاحياء
الجمعيه اشتغلت على انشاء مجالس في كل حي
عندنا اليوم اكثر من 45 مجلس حي منتشره في
المدينه وقاعد يتوسع
الجانب هذا يعني بتعزيز الاواصل
الاجتماعيه في الحي بتهيئه الاماكن لكبار
السن
الموجودين في الحي سواء كان سيدات او رجال
وحتى دعوه بعض المسؤولين الخاصين بالحي
مدير المركز الصحي رئيس البلديه المعنيه
مدير القسم الشرطه المعني للاجتماع مع
الاهل الحي ومعرفه احتياجاتهم وكذا جانب
اخر اللي هو موضوع مراكز الاحياء مراكز
الضخمه اليوم الجمعيه كذلك الامانه كان
عندها ثلاث مراكز احياء تعمل على تشغيلها
بشكل يعني
يحتاج تطوير كبير او متواضع لمستوى اس
اسندت هذه المراكز للجمعيه صارت تعمل
عليها موجود فيها مسرح موجود فيها ملعب
موجود فيها مسبح موجود فيها الصاله متعدده
الاغراض وقاعده تعمل الجمعيه شغلتها بشكل
بكفاءه عاليه جدا واليوم في اكثر من سته
مراكز احياء كبرى يعني لجمعيه تنشئه وتشرف
عليها سواء كانت من قطاع الثالث او او من
المساهمين او من الجمعيه نفسها انشاتها
لغرض يعني
تعزيز الاواصر الاجتماعيه في الحي ويعني
هذه بعض الاعمال الامانه كانت تقوم فيها
واستندات للجمعيات عندنا اليوم جمعيات
سكني عندنا اكثر من جمعيه مستهدفنا انه زي
ما في قطع خاص يدعم الامانه في تنفيذ
اعمالها وفي قطاع حكومي يدعم اعمالها يكون
كذلك في قطاع ثالث نشطه جيد يعني يدعم
الامانه في تقديم او توكل لهم ملفات يعني
تنفيذ بعض الاعمال لرفع كفاءه التشغيل في
سؤال مره غريب ابو محمد يعني بالمجمل
بالمجمل اظن علاقه سكان المدن بالامناء
ليست جيده اغلب المدن يمكن في استثناءات
فيصل العيافي الرياض يحبونه مره انت في كم
مثال اخر الاهل المدينه يحبون الامين
بس الغريب انه هذا يقول في الوقت الحالي
امير المدينه لا يستقبل المواطنين عكس
اسلافه السابقين الذين يخصصون يوما كحد
ادنى الاستقبال المواطنين وهذا تكرر كثير
فانت مقفل الباب بالعكس سنستغرب من
الملاحظه هذه لكن على فكره مش سؤال واحد
انا استغرب منها تماما في يوم مخصص عندك
لا عندنا تطبيق موجود خاص باحز المواعيد
تستطيع تحزز موعد مع الامين
وتختار في مواعيد متاحه ومع رئيس البلديه
مع الوكاله مع مدرارات تختار ما تشاء
الفكره في تنظيم المساله بالطريقه هذه حتى
تجي تلقى الاستقبال الصحيح الجواب الصحيح
يمكن افاجئك انه بعض الزوار وبعض طلبات
الزياره ما تتم لانه يحلل موضوع وينتهي
قبل يجي الشخص ترى موضوعك انتهى ومنتهي
فاستغرب لكن كم تستقبل في الاسبوع
كل يوم ساعه او اكثر وهذه خاصه الزيارات
العاديه لكن عندنا عندي لقاء دوري مع
المستثمرين عندي لقاء دوري مع رواد
الاعمال انا اروح الغرفه التجاريه وهذا
واجب رواد الاعمال عندنا ديوانيه موجوده
ديوانيه المقر كذلك نستقبل فيها بعض
المسؤولين سواء كان من مركز الحكومه من
الجهات المختلفه تتيح فيها الاستقبال
الناس فكل هذه موجوده غير اصلا انه اكثر
من 95% من خدمات الالكترونيه اصلا يعني
الشريحه اللي تجي اما تطلب استثناء ولا
كذا وهذا يمكن هذا اللي يحتاج كان فيها
تركيز كيف انه نتيحها بشكل واضح
وانتيح كذلك ورئيس البلديه يستقبل الوكيل
المعني يستقبل مدير العام يستقبل في تطبيق
الان تقدر تطلع الجوال وتشوفه وتستحجز
موعد تجي تذكر موضوعك كامل وتجي على
الموعد تلقى موضوعك يعني جاهز الرد جاهز
التفاصيل كامله وتوضح لك في سؤال على
موضوع الباصات العامه متى يتم تشغيلها
داخل الاحياء ليس فقط من الاحياء الحرم
واللي ما تشتغل الا في رمضان فقط مش
في الاقل العام حافلات المدينه مشروع
موجود سابقا كان نقل ترددي فقط من مواقع
يعني متعدده المسجد النبوي الان لا يعني
في جانبين في رمضان تشتغل بشكل ترددي من
الحرم الى المواقع المنتشره تقريبا اكثر
من 8 مواقع وفي كذلك
النقاط توقف موجوده داخل الطرق الرئيسيه
في الاعلى الطرق الرئيسيه هذا في المرحله
الاولى وهذا يعمل الان الامر الاخر موضوع
الحافلات السريعه ذات المسار المخصص هذا
واحد من المشاريع اللي
سيتم تنفيذه بالشراكه مع القطعه الخاص
انتهت الدراسات الخاصه فيه كلها مع المركز
الوطني للتخصيص الان في مرحله يعني
المراحل النهائيه للتاهيل متوقع في ديسمبر
او في بدايه العامل القادم 24 ان يتم
التوقيع للبدء في العمل كاحد المشاريع
النقل العاملي بيتم تنفيذها من قبل القطاع
الخاص
الى السؤال متى
الى متى ايقاف اراضي غرب المدينه المنوره
على البناء وازداد رخص وتجديدها انا متضرر
ما لقيت اجابه من امانه ترميها على الهيئه
والهيئه ارميها على جهات عليا نبغى نبني
اراضينا اربع سنوات من الايقاف
طبعا في مساحه محدده بسيطه في غرب المدينه
موقفه يعني
بغرض موضوع التطوير الكود العمراني سريع
معينه ستعلن كلها يعني الامانه هي جهه
تنفيذيه للايقاف ستعلن كلها في يعني اتوقع
في فتره قريبه قادمه
العشوائيات بالمدينه تقع في اهم منطقه
بالمدينه بل اهم منطقه في العالم اللي هي
المنطقه المحيطه المسجد النبوي فمتى يتم
تطويرها
جانبا حنا يمكن ذكرت لك اعرضا في اجابه
موضوع التطوير الاحياء عندنا احياء مخططه
واحياء غير مخططه وقديمه هذه لها تعامل
اخر يعني اليوم عملنا على تطوير اكثر من
سبعه احياء تطوير شامل تطوير يشمل العناصر
الرئيسيه للحياه كفايه البنيه التحتيه
الصرف الصحي المياه الكهرباء الاناره
النظافه المدرفين الاشياء هذه الاساسيه
وكيف انه حتى نرتقي شويه بالمشهد الحضري
فواجهات المباني طبعا باشتراك مع الملاك
او قطاع الثالث عندنا عمل كبير في هذا
الجانب اليوم بدينا في اكبر حي
في المدينه اكبر حي قديم في المدينه وقريب
جدا من الحرم بالنسبه النبوي
مساحته مليون في فرص تطوير عاليه بدينا في
مراحل في التخطيط والدراسه والتنفيذ في
نفس الوقت لتطويره بشكل بشكل جيد حددنا
الاحياء ايش اللي يحتاج لها تدخل يعني
كبير
وهذا ايش اللي يحتاج له لا والله تدخلات
صغيره فيها في هذا الجانب نبدا بالمسحه
الاجتماعي في الحي بشكل كامل حتى نعرف ايش
الفرص اللي موجوده في الحي ايش التفاصيل
اللي نقدر نبني عليها مين سكان الحي هل هم
سعوديين غير سعوديين اسهر عزاب عوائل هذه
كلها مهمه في التطوير لانه الحل السام
اللي كل شيء بنفس غير صحيح حتى حي عن حي
يختلف
من هو صاحب مقوله الناس تجي المدينه عشان
تموت فيها نبغى الناس تجي المدينه عشان
تعيش فيها وايش المقصود فيها الحقيقه
الامير فيصل بن سلمان وهذا كان يعني دائما
يكررها ويعني
ينادي فيها بشكل بشكل دائم انا في اللقاء
اللقاء الاول معايا يعني او لقاءات الاولى
معه
يعني هذا هو
طلب الرئيسي او توزيع الرئيسي كيف انه
الناس تعيش في المدينه والفرق بين
الحياه والموت فرق يعني كبير جدا
المدينه فيها فضل للموت
فكيف فضل الحياه الحياه فضل الحياه اكيد
يفوق فضل الموت
يعني طلبوا توجيه دائما المسؤولين كيف انه
نتحول من مدينه موت والناس تجي عشان تموت
الى انها تكون في حياه وفي متعه وفي
استمتاع وفيه فرص عمل في تعليم جيد في صحه
في نظام صحي جيد هذا الجوانب اللي ذكرت لك
اياها حقيقه هي هو يعني من يشرف عليها
ويطلبها وينادي فيها
والمسؤولين موجودين كلهم يعني مستوعبين
الفكره هذه سؤال اخير ابو محمد انت ابن
المدينه
وفي يوم من الايام حتغادى المنصب زي سنه
الحياه وحترجع مواطن من سكان المدينه
ايش الشيء اللي او المشروع او المبادره او
الاصلاح اللي اتمنى انك تتمنى انك تنجزه
ترى مليون بيدك القرار وبيدك الصلاحيه قبل
ما تغادر
مقعد الامانه
بتستغرب شوي لكن
مرتبطات يعني متعدده لكن انا اعتقد انه
الرصيف هو هو اساس يعني
اي حضاره او اي تطوير او اي تنميه
اقتصاديه في المناطق طبعا انا ما اتكلم عن
الرصيف بشكل يعني مجرد لكن كيف تكون
المباني بشكل جيد وانيق كيف العمل مكانتكم
مسجره بشكل سليم وزيد
الجمال والثقافه معديه وتنعكس على سلوك
الاشخاص وعلى طريقه تفكيره وعلى طريقه
تعامله مع الاخرين
الارتباط المجتمعي كل ما عززت الرصيف
والمساحات المفتوحه كل رابط مجتمعي كل ما
كان فيه يعني اواصر مجتمعيه جيده
فاعتقد كثير منا يسافر عشان يمشي واذا
سافر مسير واذا يعني هذه جوانب كثيره جدا
تنتعش الدوره الاقتصاديه ولاحظناها تنتعش
الاواصل الاجتماعيه والعمل المجتمعي كذلك
يعني لوحظناه في العمل فكثير حقيقه من
وطبعا انا كل كل مشروع يجي يقول والله هذا
مشروعي واتمنى اخلصه قبل هذا لكن
المواقع التاريخيه كذلك مهمه والعمل فيها
حقيقه شرف
والتطويرها كذلك شرف كل الاعمال حقيقه هي
اعتقد انها قريبه وكل عمل كل فرصه عمل
تفتح بيت ويعني تنتج تخدم اسره حقيقه افرح
فيها واتشرف اني اني كنت في يوم من الايام
عنصر من العناصر التمكين شكرا لك ابو محمد
وبالتوفيق في جعل المدينه المدينه للعيش
شكرا لك اخوي ابو عبد الرحمن الله يديك
الصحه والعافيه استمتعت في الحديث معكم
واتمنى انه يكون اللقاء يعني
وضح بعض الجوانب وحقيقه ادعوك انت كشخص
وادعو للاخوان الساده المشاهدين المستمعين
انهم يزورون المدينه ولا يعني يبخلون
علينا في النصائح او اهداءنا بعض
الملاحظات والمدينه خير لهم لو كانوا
يعلمون
شكرا لكم وشكرا في هدرك قصير في اعداد
وانتاج الحلقه ياسر كداشه او عبد المجيد
ووزير خلف الكاميرات وفي تسجيل الصوت يوسف
ابراهيم وفي التحرير محمد الديني وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف
على الانتاج رزانه هيثم هذا بودكاست سقراط
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]